je suis heureuse de souhaiter la
bienvenue à trois de nos collègues
madame
Éléonore Caro
[Applaudissements]
monsieur Meyer Habib
et Monsieur
Karim bencher
ils ont été réélus députés les 15 et 16
avril dernier respectivement dans les
deuxièmes 8ème et 9e circonscription des
Français établis hors de France donc
l'ordre du jour appelle les questions au
Gouvernement la première d'entre elles
va être posée par Monsieur Antoine
léoman pour le groupe la France
insoumise
madame la Première ministre ce 1er mai
2,3 millions de manifestants vous ont
dit dans la rue leur opposition à la
réforme des retraites en vous acharnant
vous abîmez la démocratie vous abîmez la
démocratie en utilisant les outils les
plus autoritaires de la 5e République
vous abîmez la démocratie en bafouant la
Constitution qui dit que la République
c'est le gouvernement du peuple par le
peuple et pour le peuple vous abîmez la
démocratie en utilisant la police non
pour garantir le droit à manifester mais
pour le réprimer votre bilan c'est la
violence ça suffit policier brûlé
journaliste frappé manifestants mutilés
les coupables c'est vous nous apportons
notre soutien à tous les blessés vous
opposez le peuple au peuple pas nous
vous vouliez tourner la page des
retraites c'est raté vous reportez tous
vos projets de loi vous ne savez plus où
vous allez et d'ailleurs où que ce soit
les casseroles vous accompagnent
vous ne pouvez plus gouverner la crise
est maintenant politique la Cinquième
République permet d'agir sans le peuple
et contre lui elle n'est plus légitime
en bafouant ses principes républicains
vous accélérez sa chute et la vôtre
alors oui ah bah Macron et la mauvaise
République vive la Constituante et la
Sixième République ici c'est la France
celle d'un peuple insoumis dont la
nation s'est fondée par une révolution
on ne fait pas taire le peuple on
l'écoute on ne le méprise pas on le
respecte on ne leur estime pas on lui
obéit nous ne céderons pas vous vouliez
en avoir fini le 14 juillet vous aurez
votre prise de la Bâtie vous avez déjà
perdu quand retirez-vous votre réforme
des retraites merci beaucoup nos chers
collègues la parole est à Monsieur
Gérald Darmanin ministre de l'Intérieur
et des Outre-mer
[Applaudissements]
merci la Présidente Mesdames et
Messieurs les Députés
monsieur le député Léomont pardon si je
ne suis pas forcément l'interlocuteur
que vous auriez souhaité mais j'avoue
que je n'ai pas tout compris de votre
question sauf que vous n'étiez pas
content et que vous n'aimiez toujours
pas la police
monsieur le député
je regrette très sincèrement monsieur le
député que pour la première question au
gouvernement après des violences
absolument inacceptables qui ont blessé
405 policiers et gendarmes hier
d'autres dont un policier dans ta
policier qui aurait pu comme chacun a vu
à sa télévision mourir parce qu'on
envoie un cocktail Molotov sur sa tête
et qu'il est brûlé au deuxième degré que
vous n'ayez pas un mot pour eux pour ses
paires et mère de famille démontre votre
humanisme
[Applaudissements]
mais vous nous avez habitué monsieur
léoman
monsieur le député Léonard vous nous
avez habitué vous nous aviez habitué là
où vous nous avez moins habitué c'est
pas tellement votre haine Antipolis
c'est que vous n'avez même pas un mot
pour les 3 militants du parti communiste
qui ont été agressés par les Black Blocs
et si le Parti communiste français a
fait ce matin un communiqué extrêmement
clair sautant les forces de l'ordre
protégeant le droit de manifester et
condamnant les violences des Black Box
vous êtes les complices manifestement de
ces violences quand ici devant la
représentants du peuple coûte condamnez
pas les gens qui à coup de cocktail
Molotov avant notre démocratie
[Applaudissements]
s'il vous plaît la parole est à monsieur
le Président marquant jelly pour le
groupe horizon
merci madame la Présidente mes chers
collègues aujourd'hui un jeune homme de
27 ans est hospitalisé brûlé au deuxième
degré
qu'a-t-il fait pour se retrouver dans ce
lit d'hôpital son métier
vêtu de l'uniforme il a participé aux
opérations de maintien de l'ordre de
protection des personnes et des biens
lors de la manifestation du 1er mai à
Paris c'est là qu'il a été touché par un
cocktail Molotov le blessant grièvement
je veux ici au nom du groupe horizon et
apparenté rendre hommage à ce jeune
homme au 45 policiers et gendarmes
blessés ce lundi mais également au 1083
membres des forces de sécurité
intérieure qui ont également été
victimes d'attente physique depuis le
mois de janvier
[Applaudissements]
qu'il est triste de voir que certains
représentants de la nation ne se lève
pas pour applaudir
ce drame l'utilisation d'armes
artisanales de guerre mais au grand jour
la banalisation inacceptable de la
violence envers nos forces de l'ordre
envers ces femmes et ses hommes qui
consacrent leur vie professionnelle et
trop souvent une partie de leur vie
personnelle à l'intérêt général et à la
protection de nos concitoyens en tant
que fervent partisan de l'ordre
républicain nous ne pouvons nous
résoudre à accepter les scènes de
violence auxquelles nous assistons qui
il éclaire ne sont ni improvisés ni
spontanées mais bien préparé et présidé
par une logique du désordre du chaos
d'anarchie qui vise à remettre en cause
à nier l'autorité de l'État les moments
pour qualifier de tels actes ils sont
intolérables insupportables au sens
propre du terme madame la Première
ministre ma question est donc la
suivante comment limiter les risques
auxquels sont exposés nos forces de
l'ordre dans le cadre des manifestations
actuelles auxquelles se greffe des
éléments radicaux et autres casseurs
venus casser du flic
je vous remercie monsieur le Président
la parole est à madame la Première
ministre
merci madame la Présidente Mesdames et
Messieurs les Députés monsieur le
Président Laurent Marc Angelli hier près
de 800 000 Français ont défilé à
l'occasion du 1er mai
la très grande majorité des
manifestations c'est parfaitement
déroulé et je veux saluer l'esprit de
responsabilité des organisations
syndicales et l'engagement des préfets
et défenses de l'ordre pour garantir la
liberté fondamentale de manifester et
préserver la sécurité des cortèges dans
plusieurs grandes villes notamment Paris
Lyon ou Nantes comme cela avait déjà été
le cas lors de précédentes
manifestations des groupes violents ce
sont mêlés à des cortèges pacifiques ces
groupes n'ont qu'un objectif sans
prendre aux forces de l'ordre créer le
désordre et le chaos mesdames et
messieurs les députés cette violence est
intolérable et nous devons tous
responsables publics la condamner avec
la plus grande fermeté
elle est intolérable car un
instrumentalise le droit de manifester
qu'elle éclipse les idées elle est
intolérable car elle crée des dommages
importants dans l'espace public je pense
aux commerçants aux artisans aux
entreprises aux particuliers aux maires
qui hier soir ou ce matin ont découvert
de Lourdes dégâts sur leur vitrine leur
véhicule leur mobilier urbain des
individus violence se sont même
introduits dans les domiciles personnels
de certains députés c'est inacceptable
et je veux leur dire toute ma solidarité
c'est violence sont intolérables enfin
car elles causent des blessures elles
mettent en danger les manifestants et
certains ont malheureusement été blessés
elles ont surtout pour si le les forces
de l'ordre
hier
[Musique]
plus de 400 policiers et s'il vous plaît
s'il vous plaît seul madame la Première
ministre à la parole merci de l'écouter
merci de l'écouter
hier plus de 400 policiers et gendarmes
ont été blessés dont certains
grièvements les images que nous avons vu
notamment celle d'un policier brûlé par
un cocktail Molotov sont insupportables
et illustrent qu'un nouveau palier a été
franchi dans la violence avec vous je
veux dire de nouveau tout mon soutien et
celui de mon gouvernement à nos forces
de sécurité intérieure
mesdames et messieurs les députés dans
notre pays on peut légitimement exprimer
sa colère ou son désaccord sur la voie
publique mais on ne peut pas s'en
prendre à l'intégrité physique des
femmes et des hommes qui parlent leur
uniformes incarne la République et nous
protège je veux le redire ici les
auteurs de ces extinctions seront
identifiés et traduits en justice je
vous remercie
je vous remercie madame la Première
ministre la parole est à madame la
Présidente
merci madame la présidente madame la
Première ministre si la tâchement des
mahorets à la France n'est plus à
démontrer l'attachement des
gouvernements successifs à Mayotte
manque cruellement de preuves quand les
Comores voisines refusent d'appliquer le
droit international en reprenant leur
ressortissant c'est évidemment sur la
voie ferme de la septième puissance
mondiale face à un pays de 800 000
habitants que les mahorets comptent et
non sur les propos de votre ministre des
Affaires étrangères évoquant il y a
quelques semaines encore une coopération
étroite quand les mahorets constatent
quotidiennement qu'ils n'ont quasiment
aucun droit de plus que les étrangers
souvent clandestins ils regrette
amèrement que les lois de la République
ne soient pas plus favorables à ceux qui
possèdent la nationalité française
quand les mains auraient entendent des
juges expliqués qu'il faut tout faire
pour empêcher de lutter contre
l'immigration clandestine ils prennent
le chaos sécurité et le désastre
économique qui en résulte pour une
fatalité or comme je le dis à tous les
Français je dis au Mahorais il n'y a pas
de fatalité mais bien des choix
politiques non nous n'avons pas à
financer les pays qui Bafou le droit
international et organise la submersion
migratoire de la France non nous n'avons
pas à accueillir sur notre sol les
délinquants étrangers qui bafouent les
valeurs d'asile et d'accueil mais oui
nous avons un maître un terme au
cauchemar que vivent des Français
notamment en changeant profondément une
partie de notre droit sur l'immigration
j'ai voulu savais un texte prêt à être
soumis au référendum à ce propos si vous
voulez travailler mes propositions elles
sont toujours en ligne alors madame la
Première ministre qu'allez-vous faire
pour Mayotte et plus généralement
avez-vous compris que pour ce que vivent
nos compatriotes mahoren ne soit pas ce
que vivront demain l'ensemble des
Français il faut changer radicalement de
vision et mettre en place une politique
dissuasive d'immigration
madame la Présidente mais ça mesdames et
messieurs les députés madame la
Présidente Le Pen alors votre question a
une vertu de faire entendre de nouveaux
votre voix dans cette émission après des
semaines de mutisme et de silence
mais malheureusement malheureusement
c'est de nouveau c'est de nouveau pour
vous placer dans la posture dans les
caricatures au mépris de la réalité
alors voyez madame la Présidente je
pense que les maorelles ont bien compris
le gouvernement est alors côté le
gouvernement a mobilisé des forces de
l'ordre exceptionnel pour ramener la
sécurité pour ramener la tranquillité à
Mayotte ce sont à la fois des policiers
des gendarmes des magistrats qui sont
sur place pour pouvoir dans un premier
temps
arrêtez les principaux responsables de
la délinquance à Mayotte et c'est ce qui
a été fait les principales cibles qui
avaient été identifiées ont d'ores et
déjà été arrêtés pour lutter contre
l'habitat insalubre et malgré en effet
l'arrêté que vous mentionniez le
jugement que vous mentionnez c'est
destructions sont en cours avec des
relogements à la clé dans des habitats
de qualité et par ailleurs nous luttons
évidemment aux côtés des maorets contre
l'immigration clandestine qui est un de
nos combats mais vous savez madame Le
Pen vous pouvez avoir votre point de vue
la manifestation qui s'est tenue la
semaine dernière avec plus de 1000
Mahorais en soutien à l'opération
engagée par le gouvernement et la preuve
que sur place les mahorels ont bien
compris nous sommes à leur côté je vous
remercie merci beaucoup madame la
Première ministre
la parole est à Madame Emeline kerbidi
pour le groupe GDR
madame la Présidente mes chers collègues
avant toute chose au nom du groupe GDR
je souhaite adresser toutes mes
félicitations au peuple polynésien au
parti indépendantistes Tavigny et à nos
camarades Muay Thaï brotherson Steve
Chaillou et themataille le gaïc pour
leur brillante victoire aux élections
territoriales en Polynésie française ce
weekend félicitations à eux
ma question s'adresse maintenant à
monsieur le ministre de l'Intérieur
depuis plusieurs jours les caméras sont
braquées sur Mayotte où l'opération est
un fiasco total à Mayotte l'immigration
incontrôlée et l'insécurité permanente
appelle indéniablement des solutions et
des moyens mais pour endiguer la misère
le mal logement le chômage le manque
d'eau des centaines de policiers ne
sauraient suffire la France pays des
droits de l'homme n'est pas à la hauteur
ici au lieu de mesure concrètes et
efficaces sur le long terme vous attisez
les violences vous bafouez les droits
humains
quelle impréparation les expulsions sont
jugées irrégulières les Comores refusent
de récupérer ces ressortissants et les
appels à la haine et à la violence
multiplient oui les mahorets ont droit
de vivre en sécurité ils ont le droit à
des conditions de logement décentes ils
ont droit à une vie descente mais jamais
jamais le groupe GDR ne se résignera à
l'usage de la force et de la violence
abusive contre les femmes des hommes et
des enfants dont le seul tort et d'un
autre et de n'être pas né sur la bonne
île
je suis inquiète pour Mayotte et pour la
Réunion qui assiste impuissante un
désastre dont elle ne sera pas épargnée
monsieur le ministre quelle vraie
solution avez-vous prévu pour les
mineurs isolés pour ces centaines de
personnes que les commandes refusent
pour ces familles sans toi quelle
solution pour les mahoraises et les
maorets qui sont en droit d'espérer
mieux de leur pays de notre pays je vous
remercie ma chère collègue la parole est
à Monsieur Gérald Darmanin ministre de
l'Intérieur et des Outre-mer
merci madame la Présidente dedames et
Messieurs les Députés je veux moi aussi
au nom du Gouvernement de la République
féliciter le Nouvelliste élu en
Polynésie française évidemment dire à
Monsieur broterson à Monsieur thémarou
et à l'ensemble de ceux qui composent
son exécutif que le gouvernement
s'apprête comme avec tous les
gouvernements du Pacifique travaillaient
avec eux et bien sûr saluer les
Polynésiens qui ont voté je crois deux
tours d'élection malgré des conditions
climatiques difficiles et des élections
incontestées je me tiens évidemment à
disposition du gouvernement de Polynésie
dès qu'il sera formé je réponds
directement madame la députée à votre
interrogation à Mayotte vous l'avez dit
vous-même en utilisant et je le note
vous l'avez utilisé très clairement le
mot de immigration incontrôlée c'est
vous qui l'avez dit je ne peux mieux
dire il y a à Mayotte une difficulté qui
tient à la démographie 80% des enfants
qui naissent vous le savez bien à la
maternité de Mamoudzou ne sont pas des
enfants Mahorais ils viennent souvent de
l'île des Comores mais aussi d'autres
pays comme l'Afrique des grands lacs et
de Madagascar j'ai fait de la
déstabilisation souvent de ces pays je
pense à islamisme qui touche l'Afrique
des grands lacs c'est aussi le cas où
vous le savez bien du surpopulation
puisqu'on est passé à 200 000 habitants
de plus en 20 ans à Mayotte qui pose des
tas de problèmes des problèmes de l'eau
vous l'avez dit et bien sûr des
problèmes de sécurité des problèmes
d'accès à l'alimentation à l'école ou
les enfants malheureusement au travail
souvent une demi-journée sur deux par
manque de construction d'école alors
même que nous déboursons 100 millions
d'euros pour construire des écoles à
Mayotte il faut donc maîtriser la
démographie et ça tient notamment par la
maîtrise de nos frontières mais cette
démographie est maîtrisée fait naître
aussi beaucoup de difficultés de
sécurité et le premier problème des
maorilles est un problème de sécurité il
y a madame la députée 60 personnes qui
sont dans des bancs de criminelles à
Mayotte qu'il soit français ou qui ne
soit pas français ce n'est pas le sujet
la police la justice intervienne
indisctement et sur ses 60 personnes 22
ont déjà été interpellés encore deux
personnes cette nuit grâce au travail
des gendarmes et des policiers notamment
dans les borgas dans les habitats
insalubre et c'est d'abord le
rétablissement de la sécurité à Mayotte
qui est la mère de toutes les batailles
avant d'aller vers le logement vers
l'eau et vers évidemment le progrès
social merci beaucoup
[Applaudissements]
cette seconde a les images chers
collègues
je suis le ministre l'enfer est pavé de
bonnes intentions ce ne sont pas vos
intentions que nous fustigeons mais bien
la méthode
je vous remercie la parole est au
président Mattei pour le groupe
démocrate
merci madame la présidente madame la
Première ministre vous avez annoncé la
semaine dernière votre feuille de route
pour les semaines et les mois à venir
au-delà des textes prévus le groupe
démocrate tient salué votre volonté
d'apaisement et de dialogues qui a
toujours été pour nous un principe
fondateur de notre démocratie la
mobilisation de la démontrée hier et je
veux moi aussi aujourd'hui encore saluer
le courage de nos forces de l'ordre qui
défend non seulement la liberté de
manifester mais aussi nos libertés et au
nom du groupe démocrate de Laurent
hommage nous nous sommes engagés pour
réformer notre pays pour que les
Français ressentent dans leur vie
quotidienne plus de justice plus
d'égalité d'accès aux services publics à
la santé ou à l'éducation pour qu'il
retrouve l'espoir d'un ascenseur social
qui fonctionne mieux cet engagement de
réforme est d'autant plus nécessaire
aujourd'hui avec l'annonce par l'agence
Fitch la dégradation de la note de la
France la succession de crise l'explique
très largement mais doit nous pousser à
agir pour établir équilibre de nos
comptes réduction la dépense publique
mais aussi réflexion sur notre système
fiscal pour le rendre plus juste et plus
acceptable par tous
la réforme de notre système de retraite
est un premier pas indispensable dans ce
sens pour éviter de nous endetter sur le
dos des générations futures la clause de
revoyure que nous avons faite adoptée
permettra aux partenaires sociaux et au
parlementaire de ce ressaisir la
question le moment venu dans le respect
du rythme démocratique nous devons agir
avec plus de plus de détermination que
jamais si c'est au gouvernement de
porter ses réformes c'est aussi au
Parlement de retrouver le sens du
dialogue et de travailler avec toutes
les bonnes volontés au-delà des postures
politiques pour répondre aux inquiétudes
des Français et aux enjeux qui sont
devant nous comment madame la Première
ministre comment comptez-vous organiser
ce dialogue même si nous aussi
parlementaire devrait être en capacité
de faire ce chemin je vous remercie
merci beaucoup monsieur le Président la
parole est à madame la Première ministre
merci madame la Présidente Mesdames et
Messieurs le député monsieur le
président Jean-Paul Mattei depuis 6 ans
autour du président de la République
nous travaillons pour libérer les
énergies permettre l'émancipation de
chacun notamment par le travail et pour
protéger nos compatriotes et depuis près
d'un an malgré une majorité relative
malgré ceux qui prédisaient
l'immobilisme et malgré la volonté de
blocage de certains nous avons avancé
des conjugalisations de lâche maintient
du bouclier tarifaire lancement du
recrutement de 8500 policiers et
gendarmes réforme de l'assurance chômage
tournant de la prévention médicale
accélération du nucléaire et des
renouvelables pérennisation de notre
système de retraite par répartition et
augmentation des plus petites pensions
voilà un aperçu d'un bilan solide et
concret un bilan qui n'a rien à envier à
d'autres législatures
ce bilan nous le devons d'abord à
l'unité et à l'engagement des trois
groupes de la majorité que je salue nous
le devons aussi à celles et ceux qui ont
travaillé à amender et construire les
textes au-delà des clivages partisans
mesdames et messieurs nous avons réussi
à bâtir des compromis voter des réformes
et offrir des progrès aux Français
aujourd'hui une nouvelle phase d'action
commence nous allons continuer à agir
face aux inquiétudes revendications et
parfois au colère rien ne serait pire
que l'immobilisme la seule manière
d'apaiser le pays c'est de redoubler
d'efforts pour offrir aux Français des
solutions concrètes et relevez les
grands les grands défis devant nous
c'est pourquoi après avoir consulté les
forces politiques les groupes
parlementaires les partenaires sociaux
et les élus locaux et en suivant le cap
fixé par le président de la République
j'ai présenté une feuille de route
complète la semaine dernière cette
feuille de route apporte des réponses en
fait aux préoccupations des Français et
les textes dont vous débattrer en sont
l'illustration cette feuille de route
c'est un appel à toutes les bonnes
volontés parlementaire élu locaux
partenaires sociaux nous sommes prêts à
agir nous sommes prêts à construire nous
avons montré que nous étions capables de
bâtir des compromis et nous voulons
continuer alors pour répondre aux
demandes de nos concitoyens et préparer
l'avenir de notre pays nous allons
avancer sur quatre piliers le travail le
plein emploi et la réindustrialisation
la transition écologique les progrès
sociaux et l'amélioration de nos
services publics notamment la santé et
l'éducation et le respect de l'ordre
républicain l'agenda législatif nous
permettra de soutenir ses priorités et
nous devons dans le même temps réduire
notre déficit public et accélérer notre
désendettement c'est une condition de
notre indépendance mesdames et messieurs
nous avons beaucoup à faire pour les
prochains mois nous avons beaucoup de
solutions à apporter d'inquiétude à
apaiser d'inspiration que nous devons
concrétiser au sein de l'arc républicain
toutes les bonnes volontés sont les
bienvenus alors comme depuis un an je le
redis répondons à l'appel des Français
et bâtissons ensemble je vous remercie
merci beaucoup madame la Première
ministre
[Applaudissements]
un peu de silence s'il vous plaît la
parole est à Madame Estelle Youssoupha
pour le groupe lot merci madame la
Présidente ma question s'adresse à
Madame Colonna ministre des Affaires
étrangères je veux dire ici que notre
survie parce que c'est de cela qu'il
s'agit à Mayotte notre survie ne peut
pas être l'otage des querelles
partisanes depuis plus d'une semaine des
milliers de mahorés manifestent à
Mayotte et dans l'Hexagone en chantant
la Marseillaise à plein poumons pour
réclamer plus de République et pour
soutenir l'opération en bouchou pilotée
par le ministre Darmanin que je remercie
ici français depuis 1841 nous
revendiquons notre place légitime dans
la nation notre droit à vivre libre en
paix et en sécurité dans le respect des
lois de la République comme tous nos
compatriotes nous clairement notre
gratitude aux forces de l'ordre qui
risque leur vie à Mayotte pour nous
protéger pour faire respecter nos
frontières nous remercions nos policiers
nos gendarmes mobilisés pour lutter
contre la criminalité contre
l'insalubrité des en ville et expulser
les étrangers en situation irrégulière
alors que 75% des Français soutiennent
l'opération en bouche cette opération
d'ordre public effréné par l'obstruction
comorienne les Comores qui refusent de
reprendre leur ressortissants malgré
l'accord passé avec Paris et les 150
millions d'euros que la France a versé à
ce titre les Comores qui refusent de
reconnaître Mayotte française et envoie
leur population pour asseoir leur
revendication territoriale le président
azali s'est permis de condamner
publiquement l'opération au bouchou les
organes proches du pouvoir comorien
menacent de mort et d'invasion la
population mahoraise et les élus la
diplomatie russe offre même ses services
pour prendre militairement Mayotte
madame la ministre nous n'avons pas
entendu un seul mot du Quai d'Orsay sur
cette crise diplomatique grave pas un
mot sur cette ingérence manifeste dans
nos affaires intérieures quand
admettrez-vous enfin l'inefficacité de
40 ans de Co opération avec Moroni le
nain diplomatique comorien vous a-t-il
mis en échec quelle crédibilité pour la
stratégie Indo-Pacifique si la France
n'arrive pas à défendre son territoire
face aux Comores quelle sanction
prendrez-vous contre les Comores qui
déstabilisent Mayotte je vous remercie
merci beaucoup ma chère collègues la
parole est à Madame Catherine Colonna
ministre de l'Europe et des Affaires
étrangères
[Applaudissements]
merci madame la Présidente Mesdames et
Messieurs les Députés madame la députés
Youssoupha quelques mots quelques
réalités si vous le permettez car notre
politique concernant Mayotte n'a qu'un
objectif conforté la place de Mayotte
dans la République et il n'y a qu'une
politique du gouvernement madame la
députée et le ministère de l'intérieur
comme le Quai d'Orsay travaille ensemble
à ce titre main dans la main y compris
en ce moment même
défendre Mayotte c'est d'abord réduire
la pression migratoire en provenance des
Comores l'accord de 2019 que vous
évoquez et que mon ministère a négocié
avec ce pays permet ainsi d'opérer
davantage de reconduites que vers tous
les autres pays du monde et nous
travaillons sans relâche pour que ceci
se poursuivent
le plan de développement de 2019 est un
plan pluri annuel il est en cours
d'exécution centré sur la santé et sur
la formation il permet de lutter contre
les causes profondes des migrations de
plus nous cochons nos co-finançons une
action de coopération avec la garde-côte
comorienne qui dissuade de nombreux
départs et permet ainsi de mieux
protéger Mayotte de l'immigration
clandestine
défendre Mayotte c'est aussi défendre la
souveraineté de la France sur ce
département selon la volonté de ses
habitants et depuis trois décennies
depuis
1994 très précisément la diplomatie
française parvient à mettre en échec les
tentatives de contestation aux Nations
Unies de la présence de la France à
Mayotte et vous savez madame la députée
que cette tentative existe enfin
d'effondre Mayotte s'est défendre son
intégration régionale et son
raisonnement et son rayonnement nos
diplomates mobilisent les fonds
européens ils aident Mayotte dans sa
candidature pour accueillir les Jeux des
îles et il l'associe au projet de
coopération régionale je le redis madame
la députée il n'y a qu'une politique de
la France et une seule merci je vous
remercie
beaucoup la parole est à madame la
Présidente châtelain pour le groupe
écologiste
merci madame la présidente madame la
Première ministre depuis 21 ans aucune
manifestation du 1er mai n'avait
rassemblé autant de participants si de
leur très grande majorité grâce aux
organisations syndicales et cortège sont
déroulées dans une ambiance conviviale
des incidents et des violences ont
éclatés dans plusieurs villes nous le
déplorons et nous affirmons notre
soutien à l'ensemble des blessés mais
cela ne doit pas masquer la réussite de
cette mobilisation vous espériez que les
Français se démotivent cela peut être
même qui ne puisse plus se rassembler et
que la mobilisation s'essouffle bien au
contraire nous étions des millions des
millions pour dire non à la retraite à
64 ans des millions pour revendiquer la
hausse des salaires des millions pour
vous demander enfin de nous respecter
car ce succès madame la Première
ministre c'est aussi le vôtre après 6
ans d'une politique de disruption des
droits sociaux et des constructions d'un
climat de défiance sociale et de mépris
les Français sont défendus dans la rue
pour vous dire stop et bien nous pouvons
répondre à cette demande des Français à
cette mobilisation le 8 juin prochain à
l'occasion de la Journée d'initiative
parlementaire du groupe lyaute
l'Assemblée nationale pourra enfin voter
contre cette réforme vous avez fui le
vote vous l'avez empêché le 8 juin vous
ne pouvez pas vous dérober alors madame
la Première ministre si c'est assemblée
adopte la Loi abrogeant la réforme des
retraites vous engagez-vous dès le soir
même à retirer cette réforme et
appliquer cette décision
c'est madame la Présidente la parole est
à madame la Première ministre
[Applaudissements]
merci madame la Présidente Mesdames et
Messieurs les Députés madame la
Présidente Cyrielle châtelain il y a un
peu plus de deux semaines le Conseil
constitutionnel a validé l'essentiel de
la réforme des retraites il a notamment
affirmé la pleine constitutionnalité de
la procédure parlementaire retenue pour
faire face à l'obstruction auquel votre
groupe et votre inter-groupe a participé
il a ainsi apporté une réponse claire
juridique et définitive à tous les faux
procès menés par certains cette décision
a mis fin au chemin démocratique de
cette réforme des retraites
hier certains de nos concitoyens sont
descendus dans la rue pour exprimer leur
revendication leurs inquiétudes nous
devons les entendre nous devons leur
répondre ces revendications madame la
Présidente Shetland vous le savez
dépasse largement la réforme des
retraites les manifestants les
travailleurs les Français veulent une
meilleure prise en compte de leurs
attentes vis-à-vis du travail ils
veulent des perspectives de carrière
réelle des engagements sur la formation
ou les reconversions des salaires
revalorisés une prévention de l'usure
professionnelle ou des mesures sur
l'emploi des seniors sur beaucoup de ces
sujets nous avons déjà agi et je vous
rappelle que la réforme des retraites
permet notamment la création d'un fonds
de prévention de l'usure professionnelle
d'un milliard d'euros et prend de
première mesure pour favoriser l'emploi
des seniors mais nous voulons aller plus
loin et travailler avec les partenaires
sociaux à bâtir un nouveau pacte de la
vie au travail qui répond aux attentes
des travailleurs et offrent des réponses
concrètes à leurs attentes alors madame
la Présidente Chatelain le progrès
social ne viendra pas du bruit des
casseroles mais bien de l'action résolue
et bien de la discussion avec les
partenaires sociaux c'est le sens de la
feuille de route que j'ai présenté la
semaine dernière je vous remercie merci
beaucoup madame la première minute la
parole madame la Présidente merci madame
la Présidente je pense qu'il faudrait
parfois savoir écouter la sagesse des
casseroles qui vous offre une porte de
sortie retirez votre réforme madame la
Première ministre ne vous cachez pas
derrière le Conseil constitutionnel le
Conseil constitutionnel a décidé en
droit je vous ai posé une question
politique j'attends une réponse
politique si le 8 juin s'est assemblé à
branche la réforme des retraites est-ce
qu'en fin vous la retirez pour pouvoir
apaiser le pays
je remercie madame la Présidente
la parole est à Madame Éléonore caroi
pour le groupe Renaissance
merci madame la Présidente je voudrais
d'abord remercier mes électeurs qui me
permettent d'être à nouveau parmi vous
et merci à tous ma question s'adresse à
Monsieur Bruno Le Maire ministre de
l'économie comme l'indiqué la première
ministre dans sa feuille de route la
réindustrialisation des carbonée de
notre pays est une priorité de ce
gouvernement l'objectif est double c'est
renforcer l'attractivité de la France et
accompagner notre industrie dans cette
décarbonation alors que la note de la
France a été dégradée vendredi en raison
de la trajectoire de la dette et du
déficit mais aussi des mouvements
sociaux que connaît notre pays nous
mesurons l'impact qu'une telle décision
peut avoir sur le taux auquel l'état
emprunte pour financer nos politiques
publiques et la solidarité nationale il
nous appartient donc de restaurer l'état
de nos finances et de mener une
politique ambitieuse pour que la France
soit bien au rendez-vous
des grands rangs défis du 21e siècle tel
que la transition écologique et
énergétique l'investissement public et
privé est essentiel car il permet la
création et la répartition de la
richesse nationale ainsi que
l'accélération de la transition
écologique aux États-Unis les
PlayStation le Dark Chan acte adoptée en
août dernier par le Congrès a créé un
cadre incitatif pour favoriser
l'investissement industriel transformant
l'enjeu environnemental en pivot
stratégique au profit de la puissance
américaine nos entreprises aussi ont
besoin d'un cadre incitatif clair simple
et lisible au niveau français comme au
niveau européen nous devons inciter le
développement de filière verte le projet
de loi industrie verte qui sera débattu
au Parlement cet été devra également
garantir la protection des Françaises et
des Français et de leurs emplois dans le
cadre de la réindustrialisation de notre
économie mais aussi offrir de nouvelles
opportunités de formation
pour s'engager dans les nouveaux métiers
de l'industrie verte monsieur le
ministre ma question est simple quelles
actions concrètes proposez-vous pour
bâtir une véritable industrie verte en
France et en Europe mais surtout dans
quel délai et avec quelle garantie et
perspective pour l'emploi
la parole est à Monsieur Bruno Le Maire
ministre de l'Économie des Finances de
la souveraineté industrielle et
numérique
[Applaudissements]
madame la Présidente est députée madame
la députée le Nord carrois d'abord
permettez-moi de vous renouveler toutes
mes félicitations pour votre brillante
rédaction preuve que la majorité est
vivante et forte
le projet de loi industrie verte nous
allons examiner à l'Assemblée d'ici
quelques semaines elle affirmation la
souveraineté industrielle européenne et
la réponse directe nous avons voulu
apporter avec le président de la
République et la première ministre Adira
américaine nous voulons défendre
protéger renforcer notre industrie nous
voulons le faire avec vous donc j'ai
invité l'ensemble des groupes
parlementaires à venir proposer
compléter le projet de loi industrie
verte dans les jours qui viennent et
nous serons très ouverts à toutes les
propositions de quelques groupes qu'ils
soient pour renforcer notre projet de
loi dans l'esprit de dialogue qui a
toujours été le nôtre nos pistes vous
les connaissez première piste comment
est-ce que on renforce le soutien
financier comme le font les Américains
il y a déjà des subventions pourquoi ne
pas réfléchir par exemple à des crédits
d'impôts deuxième piste comment
favoriser la commande publique
européenne et la commande publique
nationale pour mieux défendre et de
protéger nos intérêts industriels
troisième piste elle est essentielle
comment accélérer l'ouverture de
nouvelles usines il faut 18 mois en
France il faut 9 points en Allemagne
nous devons divisé par deux les délais
d'instruction des dossiers d'ouverture
ou d'élargissement des usines quatrième
piste comme en mieux financer
l'industrie verte en faisant appel
notamment à l'épargne privée des
Français et dernière piste enfin
peut-être la plus importante la plus
capitale pour notre industrie la
formation la qualification
l'attractivité des métiers industriels
pour que nous ayons demain des jeunes
qui est l'ambition et la fierté de
travailler dans l'industrie je vous
remercie monsieur le ministre la parole
est à Monsieur Philippe loto pour le
rassemblement national
monsieur le ministre de l'économie et
des finances les agences de notation
sont loin d'avoir toujours raison pour
autant forcer de constater qu'en
dégradant la note de la France à a à
moins Fitch n'a fait que le triste
constat d'une situation catastrophique
cette situation nous avons 16 de les
dénoncer 600 milliards de dettes en plus
sous le premier Macron et 150 milliards
de plus par an un déficit record de la
balance commerciale un niveau de
prélèvement obligatoire jamais atteint
alors que l'ensemble de nos services
publics se dégradent une inflation qui
pèse lourdement sur les classes
populaires et moyennes mais surtout
l'agence souligne l'impasse politique
issue du passage aux forcesv une réforme
des retraites injuste et injustifiée
source d'un chaos social qui ne peut que
nuire à notre économie ce n'est pas
faute de vous avoir prévenu vous êtes
pourtant dans le déni cette réalité et
vous avez indiqué vouloir poursuivre des
réformes structurantes mais comment
mener quelques réformes que ce soit dans
ce contexte comment poursuivre quelque
chose qui n'a pas commencé car à part
entretenir le cas où social vous refuser
les réformes de notre pays aurait
pourtant besoin pour s'apaiser ta sur
profit financier lutter efficacement
contre les fraudes mettre fin à la
submersion migratoire sortir du marché
européen d'électricité vous demeurez
jusqu'ici dans le dogue européiste du
libre-échange qui revit de nos
agriculteurs et freine la
réindustrialisation contre l'inflation
vont fuser de réduire la TVA sur
l'énergie et de la supprimer sur les
produits de première nécessité monsieur
le ministre peut sortir de la passe
quand allez-vous écouter les Français et
prendre les vrais mesures d'ailleurs
adopté par d'autres pays que vous
propose Marine Le Pen rassemblement
national je vous remercie
je vous remercie la Monsieur Bruno Le
Maire ministre de l'Économie des
Finances de la souveraineté industrielle
et numérique
[Musique]
ce qu'elle n'a jamais dit l'agence Fitz
a salué la réforme des retraites comme
une pierre indispensable au
rétablissement des finances publiques
françaises elle regrette uniquement les
blocages et les violences j'espère que
avec nous vous regrettez aussi les
blocages et les violences qui ont pu
émailler cette réforme des retraites
pour le reste quel a été nos stratégie
de finances publiques nous avons rétabli
avec cette majorité en 2017 et en 2018
l'équilibre des finances publiques la
bonne gestion des finances publiques
fait partie de l'ADN de cette majorité
nous avons eu ensuite à faire face à
trois crises et vous-même vous n'avez
cessé de réclamer à juste titre des
mesures pour protéger nos compatriotes
crises des gilets jaunes Chris du covid
dont je rappelle qu'elle a été la crise
économique la plus grave que la France
ait eu affronter depuis 1929 crise de
l'inflation avec une augmentation des
prix d'énergie la plus grave depuis le
choc pétrolier de 19 13 et bien monsieur
le député lioto face à ces crises nous
avons fait le choix de protéger
massivement nos compatriotes nos usines
nos entreprises notre industrie et nos
emplois et nous sommes fiers de cette
protection que nous avons apporté
qu'est-ce que vous auriez voulu que nous
laissions fermer les usines que nous
laissions le chômage exposé notre pays
nous avons fait le choix de la
protection maintenant nous revenons à la
normale et nous allons avec fermeté avec
rigueur avec détermination rétablir dans
les quatre années qui viennent les
finances publiques françaises nous
allons sous deux ans sortir du bouclier
sur le gaz puis du bouclier sur
l'électricité nous avons engagé sous
l'autorité la première ministre une
revue des dépenses publiques pour
réduire toutes les dépenses lorsqu'elles
sont inutiles et inefficaces pour nos
compatriotes et avec cette méthode nous
reviendrons sous les trois prochaines
déficit public en 2027 nous aurons ons
abaissé la dette et nous aurons rétabli
nos finances publiques merci monsieur le
ministre
monsieur loto oui monsieur bien j'ai un
peu l'impression que parfois vous créez
les crises que vous venez éteindre après
et malgré cette réponse que j'ai une
qualifierai pas dilatoire si je puis
dire les Français constatent en tout
état de cause que finalement la
différence entre votre gouvernement et
le Titanic c'est que le Titanic au moins
20 orchestre alors que vous n'avez des
casseroles
[Applaudissements]
je vous remercie
la parole est à Madame Karen et Rodie
pour le groupe la France insoumise merci
merci madame la présidente monsieur le
ministre délégué au transport collège le
22 avril une manifestation massive a eu
lieu contre l'autoroute a69 un projet à
rebours de l'urgence climatique des
alertes du GIEC et des objectifs de
l'agenda 2030 je le cite mettre en place
une infrastructure de qualité fiable
durable et résiliente pour favoriser le
développement économique et le bien-être
de l'être humain en mettant l'accent sur
un accès universel un coup abordable
dans des conditions d'équité l'autoroute
Toulouse Castres consommera 400 hectares
de terres agricoles des millions de
mètres cubes d'eau et détruira des
réservoirs de biodiversité pour gagner à
peine 10 minutes pour se jeter dans les
bouchons de la métropole toulousaine
sacrifiant notre souveraineté
alimentaire et notre ressource à nos si
précieuse 90% des contributions à
l'enquête publique si oppose le
commissariat d'investissement doute du
bien fondé du projet la vie de la
commission d'enquête est plutôt
défavorable le CMPN estime que ce
dossier s'inscrit dans une contradiction
avec les engagements nationaux en
matière de lutte contre le changement
climatique d'objectif 0
artificialisation nette et zéro perte
net de biodiversité ainsi qu'en matière
de pouvoir d'achat mais aussi
l'élargissement de l'infrastructure
existante RN 126 constituerait
probablement une solution à moindre
impacte plus d'un acteur acceptable et
durable avec moins de 600 véhicules
jours mesurés sur le tracé actuel cette
concession sera déficitaire vous refusez
vous refusez encore de rendre public
l'intégralité du contrat de concession
qui va payer où est l'intérêt général 17
euros aller-retour ce sera l'autoroute
des riches du lobby Pierre Fabre dans
votre député tarné et RP depuis 2017 il
se fait maintenant le VRP du groupe NGE
atosca gagnant de l'opération en
récupérant soit 75 millions d'euros
d'équipements publics déjà payés par les
Français cette autoroute est inutile et
imposée allez vous respecter monsieur le
ministre votre engagement recevoir à
revoir les projets en cours dans celui
de l'autoroute a69 et engagé un
moratoire global sur les 55 projets en
cours comme le demande de collectif
national la déroute des routes merci
beaucoup ma chère collègue la parole est
à monsieur Clément bonne ministre
délégué chargé des transports
madame la députée Karen et Roady
puisque vous ne l'avez pas fait je veux
avoir d'abord un mot pour le préfet du
Tarn les services de l'État nos forces
l'ordre l'ensemble des associations qui
se sont montrées parfaitement
responsables et qui parle dialogue et la
discussion ont permis que la
manifestation puisse se dérouler dans le
calme je salue aussi votre intérêt que
je découvre pour ce projet puisque avant
les manifestations en question vous
m'avez jamais sollicité madame la député
sur ce projet spécifique mais parlons-en
précisément puisque vous m'interrogez
c'est son projet spécifique je veux
souligner justement sur l'état
d'avancement il a fait l'objet
d'engagement contractuel il a fait
l'objet de recours puisque nous sommes
en état de droit et tous ont été
déboutés par la justice les travaux de
ce projet ont commencé ça n'est donc
plus tout à fait un projet mais un début
de réalisation est-ce que cela veut dire
que les choses ne peuvent pas
s'améliorer qu'on ne peut pas en
discuter je ne le crois pas et notamment
sur la question environnementale mon
ministère avait pris l'initiative de
réduire les impacts très
significativement ces derniers mois et
nous pouvons sans doute à cet égard
faire mieux je suis prêt en discuter
avec l'ensemble des forces politiques
qui le souhaitent j'en ai d'ailleurs
discuté toute sensibilité politique
confondues avec les élus du département
qui se sont exprimés dans une très large
majorité pour ce projet je pense au
président socialiste du département je
pense au député Jean tirelier je pense à
la prison de région Occitanie madame
Delga et je suis prêt évidemment à
poursuivre ce dialogue puisque vous
m'interrogez sur les engagements que je
prends et qui sont ceux du gouvernement
en matière écologique et autoroutière
oui nous avons lancé sur l'autorité de
la première ministre une revue de chacun
des projets en cours que nous examinons
au regard de plusieurs critères de
désenclavagement d'engagement pris et
d'impact environnemental en suivant le
rapport du Conseil rotation de
l'infrastructures nous reverrons à cet
angle projet nous prendrons les
décisions courageuses audacieuses dans
les prochains mois certains projets
seront sans doute suspendus ou mis à
l'arrêt nous aurons l'occasion d'en
discuter j'espère que vous ferez preuve
d'un esprit constructif à cet égard
[Musique]
le nez la parole est à Monsieur Philippe
Brun pour le groupe socialiste
madame la Présidente ma question
s'adresse à madame la Première ministre
madame la Première ministre dans une
interview au Figaro du lundi 24 avril
dernier le président de la République
demandait aux Français d'être patient et
d'attendre la fin de l'été afin de voir
l'inflation baissée madame la Première
ministre jusqu'à quand enfin
abuserez-vous de la patience des
Français
explosion des prix au mois de février
14,8% explosion des prises alimentaires
également au mois de mars avec
15,9%. et face à cette explosion des
prix les mesures du gouvernement s'avère
bien insuffisante augmentation
résiduelle du SMIC à hauteur de 2,2%.
augmentation indigne des minima sociaux
à seulement
1,6%. ce qui fait qu'aujourd'hui une
mère célibataire avec deux enfants qui
voient son pouvoir d'achat diminuer
chaque mois de 170 euros ne voit son
pouvoir d'achat augmenter grâce à vos
mesures que de 17 euros soit dix fois
moins que ce dont elle a besoin
insuffisante également mesure prise
contre la hausse des prises alimentaires
et je pense à votre panier entière que
vous avez dû abandonner avant même
d'avoir pu le généraliser sous la
pression de la grande distribution que
dire enfin de ce bouclier tarifaire donc
vous avez annoncé l'extinction et qui
constitue une subvention au spéculateur
du marché de l'électricité 50 milliards
d'euros par an 100 milliards d'euros en
deux ans alors le premier ministre notre
question est la suivante allez vous
prendre enfin à bras le corps la
question de l'augmentation des prix
d'abord blocage j'ai pris des produits
des premières nécessité augmentation
significative du SMIC grande conférence
nationale sur les salaires et enfin la
suspension de notre participation au
marché européen de l'électricité afin
d'obtenir une réforme ambitieuse de ce
marché et la fixation dès les prix
d'électricité sur le prix de production
les Français comptent sur vous
ministre de l'Économie des Finances de
la souveraineté industrielle et
numérique
on voudrait bien vous entendre
si vous n'avez pas multiplié au cours
des derniers mois les propositions qui
réduisent le pouvoir d'achat de nos
compatriotes et refuser de voter les
propositions qui protègent le pouvoir
d'achat de nos compatriotes vous avez
proposé de supprimer la défiscalisation
des heures supplémentaires ça veut dire
que vous réduisez le pouvoir d'achat de
ceux qui travaillent ça veut dire que
vous retirez 150 euros par an un salarié
qui travaille et qui gagne de 1000 euros
par mois c'est une attaque directe
contre le pouvoir d'achat des
travailleurs vous avez proposé de
supprimer les exonérations de cotisation
pour les bas salaires pour tous les
commerçants pour tous les artisans qui
ont des salariés c'est un retrait de
pouvoir d'achat une diminution de leurs
revenus une diminution des revenus de
ceux qui travaillent nous avons proposé
de nous notre côté et nous avons adopté
avec cette majorité l'indemnité
carburant travailleur 100 euros pour
ceux qui prennent leur véhicule pour
aller travailler vous ne l'avez pas voté
nous avons voté une Rev l'utilisation
des bourses vous ne l'avez pas voté nous
avons mis en place le gel des prix du
gaz vous n'avez pas voté nous avons mis
en place le plafonnement des tarifs
d'électricité vous n'avez pas voté vous
n'avez voté aucune des mesures qui
améliore concrètement le pouvoir d'achat
de nos copatriotes alors ne nous donnez
pas de leçons sur la lutte contre
l'inflation car cette majorité et celle
qui a le mieux protégé nos compatriotes
contre l'inflation de tous les pays
européens maintenant il reste les prix
alimentaires avec Oliver Grégoire nous
prenons le sujet à bras le corps le
trimestre anti-inflation permet d'avoir
des prix inférieurs de 5 à 7% de qu'ils
étaient avant et nous réunirons très
prochainement l'ensemble des acteurs de
la distribution pour voir avec eux
comment aller plus loin et protéger
contre l'inflation nos compatriotes je
vous remercie monsieur le ministre la
parole est à Madame Sabrina agressive
merci merci madame la Présidente nous
avons tous en tête les images d'une
violence absolue envers nos forces de
l'ordre elles sont inacceptables alors
permettez-moi madame la Présidente de
rendre hommage aux 406 gendarmes et
policiers blessés hier lors des
manifestations et de condamnés fermement
ces violences à leur rencontre ma
question s'adresse à monsieur le
ministre de l'Intérieur et des Outre-mer
la lutte contre le trafic de stupéfiants
et tout autant un enjeu de santé
publique de sécurité qu'un enjeu de
société ce trafic impacte le décrochage
scolaire partout où il prospère venant
opposer le mirage de l'égalité des
chances par l'argent faussement facile à
l'égalité des chances réelles permissent
par l'école de la République cette
activité criminelle irrigue au fond
toutes les autres et alimentent le
développement d'une Archos banditisme
source de la quasi-totalité de tous les
règlements de comptes voire de vendetta
comme c'est le cas actuellement à
Marseille monsieur le ministre vous avez
placé dès le mois de juillet 2020 la
lutte contre le trafic de drogue parmi
vos priorités le gouvernement agit à
plusieurs à plusieurs niveaux
la création de l'Office anti stupéfiant
l'OPAC la mise en place de cellules du
renseignement opérationnel sur les
stupéfiants dans chaque département ou
encore la généralisation de l'amende
forfaitaire délictuelle le consommateur
a une responsabilité considérable dans
le développement de ces réseaux la
légalisation qui a eu lieu dans certains
États notamment européens n'a pas fait
ses preuves dans la situation actuelle
en France elle serait un renoncement
dans ce contexte l'État met des moyens
renforcés inédits pour lutter contre ces
trafics et l'insécurité qui en découle
le volet sécurité du plan Marseille en
grand du président de la République
ainsi que la loi d'orientation et de
programmation du ministère de
l'Intérieur viennent considérablement
enrayer les dynamiques de ces trafic
pourtant à l'heure où la lutte contre
ces trafics n'a jamais été aussi vive
nous devons mettre en oeuvre des mesures
de désarmement financier hors norme et
massif monsieur le ministre pouvez-vous
rappeler devant la représentation
nationale la feuille de route et les
objectifs du gouvernement en matière de
lutte contre le trafic de stupéfiants je
vous remercie je vous remercie la parole
estagéeale Darmanin ministre de
l'Intérieur et des Outre-mer merci
madame la Présidente et Monsieur les
députés madame la député Sabrina je veux
saluer le travail de l'ensemble des élus
marseillais le vôtre bien évidemment de
celui des parlementaires quel que soit
leur sensibilité politique mais aussi du
maire de Marseille et de tous les élus
départementaux et régionaux pour le
travail qu'ils font en lien avec la
police nationale la préfète de police
des Bouches-du-Rhône et bien sûr le
préfet de région à Marseille vous le
savez mieux que personne il y a
malheureusement l'enquistement de la
drogue et dans tous les quartiers de la
ville et malheureusement qui touche
également ce qu'on appelle l'arrière
pays marseillais plusieurs départements
limitrophes je pense au Vaucluse je
pense aux gars je pense au Var décidez
par le Président de la République des
moyens très importants en justice mais
aussi en police pour que Marseille
retrouve de l'inquiétude ont des
résultats très importants en un an par
exemple vous le c'est 40 points de deal
en moins la cité de la paternelle que
nous avons évoquée il n'y a pas assez
longtemps que ça désormais connaît un
relatif calme et un assèchement du
trafic de drogue tout cela c'est parce
que nous mettons vous le savez des
centaines de policiers de gendarmes
supplémentaires qui tous les deux
meilleurs à Marseille interviennent
contre ces points deal c'est 30 % de
saisie de drogue en plus cocaïne et
cannabis c'est 570 garde à vue depuis le
1er janvier et c'est évidemment
énormément de moyens de police
judiciaire ces attaques font contre
trafic de drogue des règlements de
compte puisque beaucoup de gros monnaies
de la drogue sont interpellés des
conquêtes de territoire sont extrêmement
fortes et vous le savez nous avons face
à nous des gens qui sont extrêmement
armés et extrêmement puissants mais la
puissance de l'État sera d'autant plus
forte que la ville par l'augmentation
des caméras de vidéoprotection les
moyens de police judiciaire mais aussi
tout le travail de la politique de la
ville de peuplement et vous l'avez
décidé vous-même avec le président de la
République Delon rue et de l'éducation
nationale vont permettre à Marseille je
suis sûr demain et après-demain de Me
vivre qu'aujourd'hui oui c'est très
difficile où il a lutte contre le trafic
de drogue est très difficile avouons
ensemble que ça fait plus de 50 ans que
cela dure ça a trop duré et présente la
République siffle la fin du trafic de
drogue à Marseille merci beaucoup
monsieur le ministre la parole est à
monsieur Éric Ciotti pour le groupe les
républicains
merci
merci madame la Présidente ma question
s'adresse à madame la Première ministre
d'abord avant d'évoquer la situation en
Mayotte permettez-moi au nom des députés
républicains d'exprimer ma
reconnaissance mon soutien aux policiers
qui ont été blessés hier lors des
manifestations
victimes victimes de la violence de
l'extrême gauche
madame la Première ministre Mayotte vit
depuis des semaines des mois voire des
années une situation totalement
insupportable
violence pillage guetapan sont le lot
quotidien d'emmaoré cette situation elle
est due à une immigration totalement
hors de contrôle qui fait qu'aujourd'hui
il y a plus d'étrangers en situation
irrégulières à Mayotte que de citoyens
de la République française cette
situation elle a appelée à la demande
des élus et notamment du député Mansour
camardine l'opération que vous avez
initié monsieur le ministre de
l'Intérieur cette opération bambouchou
nous la soutenons et je le dis sans
réserve parce qu'elle est essentielle et
elle est importante
mais aujourd'hui aujourd'hui face au
courage des maorés face à leur
résilience la République ne peut pas
reculer or cette opération elle est à
l'arrêt du fait d'une décision
judiciaire aux motivations totalement
ahurissante mais aussi devant la force
qu'exprime les Comores face à la volonté
de la République française d'où vous le
demandons la République ne peut pas
reculer le drapeau français doit
continuer à flotter sur Mayotte pour
dire que l'immigration illégale n'a pas
sa place sur notre territoire et pour
faire en sorte que demain la métropole
ne subisse pas la situation que subit
Mayotte aujourd'hui
je vous remercie la parole est à
Monsieur Gérald Darmanin ministre de
l'Intérieur et des Outre-mer
mesdames et messieurs députés monsieur
le présidentiotti merci du soutien que
vous apportez aux forces de l'ordre et
merci de votre soutien ainsi de suite de
votre groupe et je voudrais évidemment
saluer le député sur camardine comme
Estelle Youssoupha l'a fait tout à
l'heure les deux députés Mahorais du
soutien de la l'opération décidée par
madame la Première ministre et par
Monsieur le Président de la République
cette opération c'est
des gendarmes mobiles 4 unités
supplémentaires unité de CRS de la
police judiciaire mais aussi des
magistrats des agents du ministère de la
Ville et du Logement les agents du
ministère de la Santé bref a
renforcement sans précédent de la
République à Mayotte pour répondre
monsieur le député sutier vous le savez
à l'histoire très particulière de
Mayotte qui est fait à la fois de longs
renoncements de la République mais aussi
d'une situation extrêmement difficile
que nous connaissons on a évoqué
pourquoi notamment une démographie qui
n'est plus maîtrisée sur le territoire
mahorais vous dites qu'il y a une
république qui doit pas reculer vous
avez parfaitement raison et quel que
soit les viciss monsieur le Président la
République ne reculera pas et nous
laisserons les gendarmes mobiles et les
policiers autant d'autant qu'il le
faudra à Mayotte pour que nous puissions
atteindre les objectifs de cette
opération de reprise parce que nous
travaillons à trois objectifs essentiels
le premier c'est l'interpellation des
bandes criminelles comme je l'ai dit un
tiers d'entre elles ont déjà été
interpellé cette nuit encore par les
gendarmes mobiles dans les dans les
bancs et nous allons pouvoir traduire
devant les services de Monsieur
gardez-so des profils déjà judiciarisés
et pour certains d'entre eux déjà au
moment nous parlons depuis qu'un jour
sous les barreaux cette opération est en
train d'être réussie du point de vue de
la délinquance le deuxième c'est la
destruction des mangas il y a eu
monsieur le député attention au miroir
déformant parfois du militantisme de
loin pour Mayotte mais ce n'est pas
votre cas j'en suis certain il y a eu
une décision de justice négative et il y
a eu une centaine de décisions de
justice administrative et judiciaire
positive pour l'action du préfet de
Mayotte qui fait un travail formidable
et je voudrais ici remercier nous avons
fait appel demain nous aurons un cour
d'appel de Saint-Denis la réponse et
puis troisièmement la lutte contre
l'immigration irrégulière Sri Lanka
Madagascar Afrique des Grands Lacs cela
refonctionne nous travaillons comme
animaliste à l'étranger avec les Comores
merci beaucoup monsieur le ministre la
parole est à Monsieur Benjamin Lucas
pour le groupe écologique merci
le 20 avril 2021 madame Schiappa déclaré
je lance un fond qui s'appellera le fond
Marianne avec 2,5 millions d'euros on
peut faire beaucoup de choses pour
défendre les valeurs de la République ma
première question est donc la suivante
qu'avez-vous fait des 2,5 millions
d'euros et qu'elle aura été leur impact
pour défendre les valeurs de la
République la question est en effet
légitime car depuis plusieurs médias ont
révélé au terme de neuf mois d'enquête
que ce sont vos proches qui auraient
touché des dizaines de milliers d'euros
c'est moralement et juridiquement
condamnable singulièrement au moment
quand de nos associations souffrent de
sous-financement et où certaines d'entre
elles sont criminalisées dans le cadre
de votre loi séparatisme ces
associations fictives étaient en réalité
des officines destinés à salir vos
opposants politiques à influencer les
résultats des élections présidentielles
et législatives là encore
démocratiquement moralement
juridiquement c'est condamnable ma
deuxième question est donc la suivante
quelle a été le rôle de Madame Schiappa
dans ce scandale d'État
je vous remercie la parole est à
Monsieur Gérald Darmanin ministre de
l'Intérieur et des Outre-mer
[Applaudissements]
madame la madame la Présidente Mesdames
et Messieurs député monsieur le député
Lucas je vous prie d'excuser l'absence
de Madame bac S qui est la secrétaire
d'État auprès de moi qui remplaçait pas
et qui la première lorsque les premières
informations lui sont apportées à saisis
la section générale de l'administration
et a saisi procureur de la République
qui comme vous le savez a ouvert une
enquête l'inspection générale de
l'administration premièrement saisie par
les deux pour les deux associations que
vous évoquez du fond Marianne a été
demandé pour Madame baquet de l'ouvrir
au 16 associations concernées par le
fond Marianne et le rapport de l'IGA
sera rendu monsieur député fin juin et
Madame bac ES le rendra public au
Parlement et d'ailleurs est tout à fait
disponible bien sûr puisque je crois
savoir que le Sénat fait savoir qu'il y
aurait une commission d'enquête le
gouvernement bien sûr répondra en toute
transparence et a déjà fourni aux deux
commissions et notamment à Monsieur
Coquerel pour ceux qui concerne la
semaine nationale l'ensemble des
documents comptables je m'étonne
d'ailleurs vous n'avez pas fait
référence à ces documents qui vous ont
été four voilà une quinzaine de jours je
veux dire ici Monsieur le Député d'abord
mon soutien à la ministre délégué
Marlène Schiappa je veux par ailleurs
dire monsieur député que non ce ne sont
pas nos amis les personnes qui ont été
évoquées dans la presse je ne les ai pas
reçus je ne les connais pas j'ai jamais
dîner ou déjeuner avec eux donc éviter
de faire des comparaisons qui sont
endurières et sur la communication
politique pour gagner une présidentielle
c'est une association qui a notamment
fait de nombreuses vidéos et de nombreux
tweets pour m'insulter personnellement
donc avouer qu'on fait plus utile c'est
vrai que c'est assez partagé par
d'autres associations a également vous
avez bien raison parfois politisés donc
qui ait eu qu'il y ait eu
dysfonctionnement nous allons voir ce
que dira le procureur de la République
bien évidemment le rapport de l'héga qui
sera rendu public et la commission
d'enquête et nous prendrons les
sanctions nécessaires qui a eu des
tourments non mais là je crois que vous
faites un peu de politique politicienne
cependant n'est pas surpris
je vous remercie monsieur le ministre
allez-y mon cher collègue
si dans 200 ans des historiens venaient
à vouloir dater le macroniste il
pourrait dire nez avant la honte
franchement
vous avez avec ce fond Marianne salut la
mémoire de Samuel Paty qui appelle la
décence et la dignité vous faites en
permanence dans cette émission et à
l'extérieur des leçons sur le respect
des institutions or tout témoigne que
vous manquez de l'impartialité dans la
conduite des affaires de l'État tout
témoigne de la ferrisme qui occupe les
bancs du gouvernement tout témoigne du
fait que vous salissez les institutions
notre démocratie et notre pacte
républicain en l'occurrence dans la
crise démocratique que nous connaissons
ces criminels
je vous remercie
la parole est à Monsieur Hubert vulfran
pour le groupe GBR
[Applaudissements]
madame la Présidente Mesdames et
Messieurs les membres du gouvernement et
non la page n'est pas tournée
une mobilisation historique le 1er mai
un référendum toujours possible et dès
le début juin et bien 48 heures où vont
à nouveau se conjuguer mouvement social
et initiative parlementaire afin
d'abroger votre projet de retraite à 64
ans voilà de quoi
occuper vos 100 jours 100 jours vous
allez continuer à traîner cette
casserole avec d'autres Vichères
salaires bloqués 100 jours pour que la
majorité des Français qui s'y oppose à
cette réforme et bien décroche la
timbale de son retrait
et comme cette réforme n'a pour but que
de donner satisfaction au marché
financier et à l'Europe libéral un
conseil arrêtez tout de suite de vouloir
charger la barque en effet rumeurs ou
par humeur et malgré les propos sur la
petite chasse au gaspille tout à l'heure
défendu par Monsieur Bruno Le Maire et
bien vous prépareriez bel et bien
méthodiquement précisément mécaniquement
la baisse de 5% des dépenses utiles de
l'État santé éducation logement
environnement et toujours toujours sans
envisager un seul instant de dégager des
recettes sur les aides publiques aux
grandes entreprises ou de mettre à
contribution leur profit alors ma
question est simple êtes-vous
définitivement
adepte de la politique de la terre
brûlée sociale je vous remercie mon cher
collègue la parole est à Monsieur
Olivier du soft ministre du Travail de
l'insertion et du plein emploi merci
madame la Présidente
permettez-moi Monsieur le Député avant
de répondre à votre question sur la
politique sociale de vous adresser à
vous et en réalité aux militants du
parti communiste qui ont été prises à
partie hier dans les manifestations un
soutien républicain à ceux qui tenaient
les stands qui ont été attaqués mais
aussi à ceux de vos dirigeants qui ont
pu être conspués au faire l'objet de
propose hostiles dire aussi monsieur le
député que si nous pouvons nous
retrouver sur une certaine idée du débat
démocratique je ne partage évidemment
pas l'orientation de votre question le
gouvernement mène une réforme des
retraites vous le savez celle-ci la
première mise l'a dit tout à l'heure a
fait l'objet à la fois d'une
concertation puis d'un débat au
Parlement pendant presque 200 heures qui
a débat qui a permis d'avancer et qui a
permis d'avoir un texte meilleur que
celui que nous aurions pu présenter il y
a quelques mois aujourd'hui nous
extrêmement attentif aux conditions de
mise en oeuvre de cette réforme mise en
oeuvre qui est d'autant plus importante
qu'au premier septembre au-delà des
mesures d'âge sont aussi d'autres
mesures qui vont entrer en vigueur le
relèvement des plus petites pensions les
nouvelles modalités d'éligibilité aux
retrait au départ anticipé pour carrière
longue la mise en place du Fonds
professionnels à hauteur d'un milliard
d'euros la création de l'ouverture
pardon de la retraite progressive à la
fonction publique qui en était jusqu'à
leur privé et la simplification la
simplification de l'accès des salariés
du secteur privé à cette même retraite
progressive nous travaillons pour que
l'ensemble de ces mesures soient mises
en oeuvre au mois de septembre de
manière à ce que l'équilibre que nous
avons recherché soit bien au rendez-vous
cette réforme monsieur le député
évidemment qu'elle reste vous avez dit
c'est un sparadrap ou peut-être
avez-vous comparer cela avec un autre
ustensile elle reste dans nos mémoires
collectives mais ne doit pas nous
empêcher de travailler elle ne doit pas
nous empêcher d'avancer c'est la raison
pour laquelle nous avons dit avec la
première ministre la totale
disponibilité du gouvernement pour
discuter concerter et même ouvrir des
négociations avec les partenaires
sociaux sur un ensemble des sujets
l'emploi des seniors n'étant d'autres
peuvent être évidemment inscrits alors
du jour de l'agenda social que nous
espérons voir bâti pour le début de
l'été je vous remercie monsieur le
ministre la parole est à Monsieur
Nicolas Paco pour le groupe Renaissance
merci madame la Présidente Monsieur le
Ministre du Travail du plein emploi et
de l'insertion chers collègues hier nous
avons fêté le travail dans un contexte
où le plein emploi est à portée de main
depuis 2017 nous avons recréé 1,7
millions d'emplois nous avons relocalisé
des industries nous avons investi
massivement dans l'apprentissage
nous continuons à avancer au service de
la France et des Français pour que le
redressement de notre pays se
poursuivent et ce même si certains
tapent sur des casseroles plus graves
hier ce sont les domiciles privés de
parlementaires de la majorité qui ont
été visés permettez-moi madame la
Présidente d'adresser tout mon soutien à
mes collègues et à leur famille
plus que du bruit des casseroles
j'aimerais vous parler de ces
entreprises industrielles qui les
conçoivent les fabriques à l'image de
Christelle fleurons industriels de mon
territoire que nous avons eu le plaisir
de visiter vendredi dernier avec ma
collègue Aurore berger
Christelle c'est une centaine de
salariés au savoir-faire d'exception
tous attacher à l'entreprise est fier
devrait à l'excellence de la marque
Christelle se sont des dirigeants qui
ont pris tous les risques pour reprendre
cette entreprise devenue entreprises à
mission leader en articles culinaire
haut de gamme Christelle s'est avant
tout une aventure humaine dans laquelle
dirigeant et salarié soit la recherche
permanente de l'excellence et d'une
éthique de qualité
parlons de ces hommes et de ses femmes
chefs d'entreprise salariés soyons fiers
de nous entreprises ils sont tous les
acteurs de la compétitivité retrouver
ainsi mais les richesses produites par
le travail doivent être mieux réparties
ainsi Monsieur le Ministre j'aimerais
savoir quelle mesure concrètes
envisagez-vous pour encourager les
entreprises qui font des profits à mieux
rémunérer leurs salariés
c'est la parole est à Monsieur Olivier
du sable mais je travaille du plein
emploi et de l'insertion merci madame la
Présidente Mesdames et Messieurs les
Députés monsieur le député Paco d'abord
je partage avec vous une forme de
satisfaction satisfaction collective
l'économie française depuis 2017 a créé
un million 700 000 emplois et c'est ce
qui a permis le taux de chômage de
passer de 9,5 à 7,2 %. c'est la
démonstration que le plein emploi est
atteignable et non seulement le plein
emploi est atteignable mais c'est un
emploi de bonne qualité puisqu'en 2022
la part des CDI dans le total des
embauches n'a cessé d'augmenter et
aujourd'hui les CDI représentent une
majorité des contrats de travail conclus
de manière globale à l'échelle de notre
pays si le plein emploi est atteignable
il faut que le plein emploi soit ici
synonyme de bonne emploi et c'est un
synonyme de partage de richesse vous me
dites quelles sont les intentions du
Gouvernement pour améliorer ce partage
des richesses il y en a trois en réalité
la première c'est de veiller à la bonne
mise en oeuvre d'un texte que vous avez
voté que la majorité présidentielle a
voté avec le renfort de toutes celles et
ceux qui l'ont souhaité en juillet 2022
pour faciliter les accords
d'intéressement dans les entreprises la
prise de moins de 50 salariés pour faire
en sorte que la prime de partage de la
valeur soit pérennisée avec des
dispositions qui permettent de la rendre
incitative ce texte de 2022 est un bon
texte qui permet à toutes les
entreprises qui le souhaitent d'avancer
et de faciliter le partage de la valeur
à leur échelle et avec des conditions de
souplesse qui sont intéressantes la
deuxième chose que nous voulons faire
c'est veiller à ce que la dynamique des
négociations dans les branches
négociations salariales soient bien
présente les revalorisations successives
du SMIC ou du fait de l'indexation sur
l'inflation font que le SMIC a augmenté
a augmenté pardon de 6,2% sur la
dernière année et de 8,9% depuis le
début 2022 il y a une obligation qui a
été renforcée par la loi de juillet que
j'ai évoquée que j'ai évoqué c'est
d'ouvrir des négociations salariales à
chaque fois qu'un minima conventionnel
devient inférieur au SMIC je réunis
prochainement le comité de suivi des
négociations salariales justement pour
garantir la bonne application et
l'ouverture des négociations salariales
branches par branche puis enfin il y a
un troisième outil c'est l'accord
national interprofessionnel sur le
partage de la valeur il a été signé par
trois organisations patronales et par
quatre des cinq organisations syndicales
représentatives il facilite là encore
des dispositifs de partage de la valeur
et nous vous proposerons dans les
prochaines semaines de le transposer de
manière intégrale les fidèle merci
beaucoup monsieur le ministre la parole
est à Madame Annie je ne va pour le
couplet républicain
madame
la politique de votre Ministre
d'éducation nationale concernant
l'enseignement privé est
incompréhensible et dangereuse on
attendrait d'un ministre d'éducation
nationale qu'il s'attaque résolumente
l'école publique le niveau de nos élèves
qui ne cesse de se dégrader comme un
atteste toutes les évaluations les
attaquants règles contre la laïcité d'un
islamisme conquérant le harcèlement
scolaire qui tue l'insécurité qui
gangrène certaines de nos écoles au lieu
de quoi il a choisi de s'en prendre à
l'école privée le moyen de résoudre ces
problèmes l'obligation de mixer sociale
comme si celle-ci n'existait pas dans le
privé cette politique pétrie d'idéologie
est assortie de menaces non dissimulées
si les écoles privées ne se plient pas à
ce nouveau diktat le ministre a
récemment déclaré sur une radio de
service public que les moyens seraient
diminués pour les récalcitrants quelle
valeur peut avoir un protocole signé
sous une telle menace je passe sur la
méconnaissance de la la qualité de
l'immense majorité de ces établissements
privés de province qui scolarisent des
enfants venus de tous les milieux pour
quelques établissements publics ou
privés d'ailleurs qui ont choisi
d'opérer un recrutement fondé sur
l'excellence dont notre pays a besoin et
votre ministre lui-même ne l'a pas
dédaigné à titre personnel vous courrez
le risque insensé de rallumer une guerre
scolaire et plus grave vous passez à
côté du seul combat qui vaille offrir à
tous les enfants de la République un
enseignement de qualité dans un
environnement paisible madame la
Première ministre n'y a-t-il pas mieux à
faire pour restaurer l'école publique
que de mettre à mal la liberté de
l'école privée
je vous remercie ma chère collègue la
parole est à Monsieur Papa ministre de
l'éducation nationale et de la jeunesse
merci madame la Présidente Mesdames et
Messieurs les Députés madame la député
Geneva les craintes que vous exprimez
sont très largement infondées et je vais
vous expliquer pourquoi d'abord parce
que les questions les questions de
mixité sont des questions qui sont
relatives au niveau scolaire il y a des
études toutes convergence qui montrent
que ce soit en France ou ailleurs que
favoriser la mixité c'est améliorer le
niveau scolaire c'est également
améliorer le climat scolaire et on
pourrait même dire améliorer le climat
social en général or la situation
française n'est pas tout à fait
satisfaisante à cet égard nous donnons
priorité lorsque nous réfléchissons sur
question sur ces questions au public
voyez par exemple la réforme d'Affelnet
qui a à Paris par exemple a permis
d'augmenter de manière significative le
taux de boursier dans des
rétablissements qui en recevaient peu je
pense pour ne prendre que cet exemple au
lycée Henri IV au lycée Louis Legrand
qui ont doublé en l'espace d'une année
leur taux de boursier nous réfléchissons
également avec les collectivités à
améliorer la sectorisation à implanter
des filières d'excellence là où il n'y
en a pas et d'autres choses de ce genre
enfin les acteurs du privé sont
également demandeurs de travailler avec
nous dans le respect du libre choix des
familles nous sommes en dans le respect
du libre choix des familles monsieur le
député je le confirme et donc nous
sommes en
échange très constructif avec un certain
nombre de ces acteurs dont le
secrétariat général de l'enseignement
catholique et nous sommes en accord sur
beaucoup de points donc je ne vois pas
pourquoi il vous faudrait de votre côté
être en quelque sorte plus royaliste que
le roi il n'y a pas de guerre que je
connaisse qui commence par un protocole
de paix je vous remercie monsieur le
ministre madame Genval oui
le ministre je vous ai entendu sur
France Inter vous avez dit la chose
suivante si les établissements privés ne
respectent pas la mixité sociale et bien
nous leur diminuerons leurs moyens en
termes de ressources humaines vous
l'avez dit est-ce que ça s'appelle ça un
dialogue constructif avec l'école privée
je ne le crois pas je vous remercie ma
chère collègue la parole est à Monsieur
Roger Vico pour le groupe socialiste
merci merci madame la Présidente m'a pas
ma question s'adresse à monsieur le
ministre de l'Intérieur
monsieur le ministre depuis plusieurs
mois maintenant les nombreuses et
massives manifestations qui se déroulent
dans notre pays à la en opposition à la
réforme des retraites ont mis en lumière
un autre débat qui a été évoqué
plusieurs fois cet après-midi celui de
la doctrine d'emploi des forces de
l'ordre et des violences de part et
d'autre qui accompagnent ces
mobilisations populaires bien entendu
bien entendu et nous l'avons maintes
fois répété nous condamnons sans aucune
nuance toutes les violences d'où elles
viennent il est absolument
indiscutable que des fauteurs de
troubles particulièrement bien organisés
se sont attaqués ces dernières semaines
à la police nationale considérée par eux
comme une cible privilégiée c'est bien
entendu à la fois scandaleux et
inacceptable hier encore plusieurs
centaines de policiers ont été les
victimes vous l'avez rappelé tout à
l'heure mais il est tout aussi
indiscutable
que certains membres de la police
nationale ont adopté un comportement que
je considère comme indigne de leur
fonction et un digne des valeurs qu'ils
sont censés porter au sein de notre
République
les médias ont largement relayé des
images de manifestants pacifiques
syndicalistes retraités salariés
étudiants parfois même des familles
aveuglément molestées dans une stratégie
de maintien de l'ordre qui nous apparaît
aujourd'hui monsieur le ministre comme à
la fois nébuleuse et incertaine à
travers ce dérives certes exceptionnel
c'est la liberté de manifester qui est
mise en cause et ce faisant et se
faisant toutes les valeurs sur
lesquelles s'appuie notre pacte
républicain monsieur le ministre
pouvez-vous nous éclairer sur ce point
ces policiers ont-ils agi agistils au
coup par coup spontanément de manière
autonome ou obéissent-ils à des
instructions précises qui ainsi
participent à l'escalade de la violence
dans là où l'autre cas vous en
conviendrez cela pose problème merci je
vous remercie la parole est à Monsieur
Olivier Véran ministre délégué chargé du
renouveau démocratique et porte-parole
du gouvernement
merci madame la Présidente Mesdames et
Messieurs les Députés monsieur le député
rogerico merci d'abord pour votre
question merci surtout d'avoir condamné
les violences qui ont été constatées
dans certaines villes de France à
l'occasion de ces manifestations je
pense que c'est important moi je ne
partage pas du tout ce que dit Mélenchon
quand il parle de mauvaises République
je suis convaincu qu'il n'y a pas de
bonne et de mauvaises républiques par
contre il y a sans doute des bons et des
mauvais manifestants mais bon
manifestants c'est ceux qui viennent
avec une revendication sociale un 1er
mai ou un jour de mobilisation qui
manifeste en famille parfois entre
collègues et qui veulent porter un
message dans la parole avec la parole
publique le mauvais manifestant c'est
celui qui honnêtement je pense se moque
totalement de la cause pour lesquelles
il vient manifester mais qui vient armer
avec des barres de fer des boules de
pétanque parfois des bidons d'essence et
qui vient là pour en découdre entre
guillemets peu importe le flacon pourvu
qu'on est l'ivresse
monsieur député face à cela les forces
de l'ordre elles ont un objectif le
premier objectif et je pense qu'il faut
à chaque fois le marteler le rappeler
c'est de commencer par garantir la
sécurité des manifestants eux-mêmes pour
que les bons manifestants qui viennent
revendiquer puissent le faire en toute
condition de sécurité moi je me mets à
la place d'un CRS d'un policier d'un
gendarme qui est couvert avec un casque
pour pouvoir se protéger qui reçoit des
boules de pétanque qui reçoit parfois
des bidons d'essence voir des cocktails
Molotov comme on l'a vu et qui arrive à
conserver son calme et son
professionnalisme pour s'orienter
orienter toute son action vers la
protection des Français qui manifestent
librement dans nos rues moi franchement
excusez-moi mais ce qui me choque avant
tout c'est d'abord cela et j'aimerais
bien que 80% des prises de parole de la
gauche quand il s'agit de cela viennent
condamner d'abord ceux qui agressent les
policiers avant de commencer par
condamner les policiers qui se défendent
tant bien que mal est-ce qu'il y a
est-ce qu'il y a des abus est-ce qu'il y
a des situations de tension est-ce qu'il
y a des situations de débordements oui à
l'évidence et les images le montrent et
à chaque fois qu'il y en a qui sont
identifiés
l'inspection générale des forces de
police et saisies et des procédures sont
engagées parce que les policiers sont
porteurs de l'autorité de la République
parce qu'ils sont défenseurs non pas de
la mauvaise ou de la bonne République
mais la République pour tous les
Français merci beaucoup monsieur le
ministre
la parole est à Monsieur William
Martinet pour la France insoumise
merci madame la Présidente ma question
s'adresse à Monsieur Jean-Christophe
combe ministre des Solidarités monsieur
le ministre le 22 juin 2022 une enfant
de 11 mois et décédée des suites d'un
empoisonnement dans une crèche du groupe
people and baby ce drame a eu l'effet
d'un électrochoc il a libéré la parole
des parents et des professionnels
concernant la maltraitance des enfants
au sein des crèches privées lucratives
nous parlons d'humiliation de privation
de violence verbale ou physique
plusieurs plaintes ont été déposées pour
dénoncer ses abus je salue le courage
des parents qui engagent ces procédures
longue coûteuse éprouvante je sais
qu'ils agissent au nom de l'intérêt
général monsieur le ministre je vous
propose de vous inspirer du courage de
ses parents il est temps de reconnaître
que la marchandisation du secteur de la
petite enfance décidé il y a 20 ans est
une folie
c'est crèches privées sont arrosées de
subventions publiques qui représentent
les deux tiers de leur chiffre
d'affaires et qui payent les dividendes
des actionnaires les actionnaires
parlons-en le groupe babylou par exemple
a comme actionnaire majoritaire le front
Antin infrastructure 2,6 milliards de
capitalisation boursière des
investissements dans les pipelines en
mer du Nord la fibre optique au Pays-Bas
où le ferroviaire en Italie vous
conviendrez que nous sommes bien
éloignés de la puériculture l'exigence
de rentabilité de ses fonds
d'investissement se répercutent sur la
gestion des crèches des personnels non
qualifiés sont recrutés les taux
d'encadrement ne sont pas respectés les
économies sont faites à tout prix deux
couches maximum par jour à témoigner une
professionnelle
usine Afrique au détriment des enfants
ce sont les mots d'une cadre d'une
entreprise de crèche monsieur le
ministre votre propre administration
ligace tire la sonnette d'alarme en
dénonçant je cite des dérives
inacceptables car elles suivent une
logique exclusivement financière Liga
toujours fait le parallèle entre les
crèches privées lucratives et le
scandale des EHPAD ORPEA et Korian
monsieur le ministre il est temps d'agir
allez-vous mettre un terme à ce système
qui maltraite nos enfants au nom de
l'argent roi allez-vous enfin bâtir un
véritable service public de la petite
enfance je vous remercie je vous
remercie
la parole est à Monsieur Jean-Christophe
conbon ministre des Solidarités de
l'autonomie et des personnes handicapées
merci madame la Présidente Mesdames et
Messieurs les Députés monsieur le député
Martinet merci pour votre question qui
me permet de revenir sur le très bon
rapport que ma remis le 11 avril dernier
l'Inspection générale des affaires
sociales que j'avais moi-même diligenté
en juillet une semaine après ma
nomination il faisait suite au drame
absolument épouvantable qui était
intervenu dans une crèche à Lyon une
petite fille avait perdu la vie et aux
nombreux dysfonctionnements qui nous
sont remontés depuis le rapport vous
l'avez dit il fait des constats
extrêmement forts il décrit d'abord des
situations qui sont très hétérogènes
vous décrivez une situation très noire
mais il faut quand même dire que dans la
grande majorité des cas les
professionnels exercent leur fonction
d'un bonnes conditions et je voudrais
saluer leur engagement et que la très
grande majorité des crèches dans notre
pays assure la qualité de l'accueil et
la sécurité des enfants
il dit aussi que on a une intégration
bien insuffisante des connaissances
autour du jeune enfant dans les
formations des professionnels mais aussi
dans les projets éducatifs des
établissements et il revient également
sur l'insuffisance de certaines règles
de financement et des contrôles et 39
propositions que fait le rapport sont
actuellement en cours d'expertise et je
m'engage à y donner suite dans les
semaines qui viennent deux priorités me
guide dans cette action la première bien
sûr c'est d'assurer la sécurité et la
qualité d'accueil dans les crèches dans
tous les établissements qui soient
public associatifs ou privés d'ailleurs
dans la continuité de la charte
d'accueil qui avait été institué à
l'occasion de la législature précédente
mais je tiens le dire les
dysfonctionnements ils sont partout et
pas seulement dans les groupes que vous
citez mais oui il y a certains modèles
les modèles de micro-crège page ou les
grands groupes qui doivent attirer notre
attention et qui relève des fragilités
particulières et donc nous y
travaillerons dans le cadre de la mise
en place du service public de la petite
enfance merci beaucoup monsieur le
ministre la parole est à Monsieur
Christophe Blanchet pour le groupe
démocrate
merci madame la Présidente jeudi dernier
le séjour de cohésion du service
national universel c'est terminé pour
des milliers de jeunes à travers la
France je souhaite vous dire les mots
d'Andreas 16 ans un jeune non volontaire
que j'ai rencontré lors de mes visites
des centres en Normandie il dit j'ai
apprécié la cohésion la bonne ambiance
le SNU change totalement du cadre
scolaire du lycée au début ça ne m'a pas
plu mais au bout de deux jours je me
suis habitué au rythme et au final je
trouve ça bien la levée des couleurs
c'est le moment que je préfère car on
est tous ensemble c'est impressionnant
et on s'y habitue et ça devient naturel
les encadrants sont top
emmener les jeunes vers d'autres
horizons les sortir de leurs habitudes
et leur donner des repères patriotiques
qui font la cohésion nationale pour
apprendre à aimer la France c'est ça
aussi le SNU pour autant ces jeunes
majoritairement volontaires que j'ai
rencontré m'ont dit que le SNU devait
rester incitatif pour l'instant il doit
apparaître comme une opportunité non
comme une contrainte il doit apparaître
comme une chance plus qu'une obligation
pour rester respecter cette vision
investir dans la fidélisation des
encadrants et primordial je tiens à
saluer toutes ces encadrants volontaires
qui prennent sur leurs congés ou leur
temps personnel et qui sont l'âme du
service national universel pour être à
la hauteur l'investissement dans des
structures d'accueil pérenne semblent
inéductables pour être à l'abri de la
spéculation dans le parc privé et pour
ne pas empiéter massivement sur les
propriétés de l'éducation nationale ne
peut-on pas penser autrement en
mutualisant les futurs centres de
réserviste dans chaque département pour
accueillir des jeunes du s&u nous
pourrons pas aussi généraliser les
centres de services militaires
volontaires dans chaque région pour
qu'ils aient cette double fonction SMV
SNU madame la ministre quel est votre
feuille de route pour fidéliser les
personnes encadrant et pour créer ces
structures pérennes en profitant la LPM
gardons l'ambition d'accueillir demain
chaque jeune dans les meilleures
conditions possibles et de leur proposer
un SNU toujours amélioré qui les
incitera à vouloir le faire même s'il
devenait est obligatoire je vous
remercie mon cher collègue la parole est
à Madame
rah de la jeunesse et du service
national universel
merci madame la Présidente Mesdames
Messieurs les Députés monsieur le député
Blanchet je vais d'abord commencer par
saluer votre engagement auprès des
jeunes du service national parce que
vous faites le choix monsieur le député
d'aller dans les cendres et
d'accompagner ces séjours et je profite
de cette prise de parole monsieur le
député pour inviter l'ensemble des
parlementaires quel que soit leur banque
si le souhaitent à venir dans ces
centres aller à la rencontre de ces
encadrés allez à la rencontre de ces
jeunes et de voir à quel point ce projet
est tellement si batteur et ce projet
permet de la mixer mais loin des
caricatures loin du travail de SAP que
vit aujourd'hui le service national
universel monsieur le député bien sûr
qu'il faut accompagner accompagner ce
son développement faire que ce service
national universel qui est aujourd'hui
une chance une chance de rencontres
entre des jeunes qui ne se
rencontreraient pas par ailleurs permet
leur permet de faire grandir leur amour
dans la France de vivre des moments oui
des moments patriotiques parce que c'est
c'est absolument essentiel mais aussi de
se découvrir de se découvrir autrement
d'avoir plus confiance en eux de
découvrir parfois les gestes qui sauvent
d'autres fois
la rénovation des chantiers par trimoine
parfois des questions de santé au-delà
de soi de créer une force mentale et
morale au sein de cette jeunesse et de
cette génération monsieur le député
votre question est très clair comment
pérenniser quel est le cap la mission
qui m'a été donnée par le Président de
la République et de permettre que cette
chance soit une chance pour tous et
c'est ce que nous faisons avec le
ministre de l'éducation nationale et
ministre des armées pour que ce soit une
chance pour tous mais sous l'autorité de
la première ministre et dans le
programme et bien des priorités j'ai la
mission particulière de renforcer la
question logistique du service national
universel et donc dans l'ancré sur nos
territoires pour que ce soit une chance
pour nos jeunes mais aussi une chance
pour nos territoires et bien nous
travaillons à ce que chaque maire chaque
présidente conseil départemental qui
souhaite présenter un bâtiment qui
puisse accueillir demain des centres
Perrins des centres qui permettraient
évidemment aux jeunes d'être accueillis
tout au long de l'année puissent
évidemment postuler qu'on puisse étudier
cette opportunité parce que demain
monsieur le député les jeunes pourront
être accueillis je l'espère tout au long
de l'année avec des encadrants fidélisés
parce que la qualité passera par
l'accompagnement des encadrés en
information je vous remercie je vous
remercie madame la ministre la parole
est à Monsieur Fabrice brun pour le
complet républicain
merci merci madame la Présidente
Monsieur le Ministre de la Santé début
avril vous affirmiez dans les médias
qu'aucun service ne fermerait le
problème c'est que depuis des hôpitaux
sont pour la première fois contraint de
fermer les urgences et la nuit faute de
mettre 5 comme à Aubenas où l'événement
des CHU complique encore la situation
dans un bassin de santé où la vie des
cent mille habitants et mis en danger et
où les soignants souffrent où les
pompiers les ambulanciers les
professionnels de santé subissent au
quotidien les conséquences collatérales
de ces fermetures sur le ministre cette
situation ne peut plus durer dans un
pays qui consacre autant à ses dépenses
de santé venez au Bona venez mesurer que
malgré ses bons sentiments la loi riste
aggrave encore les inégalités
territoriales pour les hôpitaux éloignés
des CHU et des grandes agglomérations
et de grâce épargner nous le couplet sur
la transformation numérus clausus en
numerus apertus qui ne change pas
fondamentalement les choses vous le
savez la réalité c'est que nous nous
formons toujours pas assez de médecins
et de soignants six ans que votre
majorité est au manette alors fini le
bricolage fini les mesurettes au rameau
les grands remèdes paquet sur la
formation investissement dans les facs
de médecine confiance aux jeunes
Français méritants contraint aujourd'hui
de s'expatrier pour étudier c'est quand
même un comble attractivité des métiers
du soin nous faisons des propositions
régulation
réquisition interdiction de remplacement
dans le privé pour les mercenaires voilà
des mesures fortes et pourtant et
pourtant rien de tout ça dans la feuille
de route du gouvernement annoncé la
semaine dernière monsieur le ministre il
y a urgence
répondez nous enfin avec du concret
je vous remercie mon cher collègue la
parole est à Monsieur François Brown
ministre de la santé et de la prévention
merci madame la Présidente Mesdames et
Messieurs les Députés monsieur le député
Fabrice brun depuis effectivement un
mois nous mettons en application une loi
qui a été votée dans cette émission la
fameuse loi risque dont vous parlez il
était temps de la mettre en application
parce qu'elle limite les dérives de
l'intérim médical c'est même des rives
de l'intérim médical qui sont une plaie
pour le service public hospitalier et
qui contribue très largement à la fuite
des médecins de notre hôpital public
cette mise en application de la loi elle
se conjugue également avec un
renforcement un travail avec les
organisations syndicales un renforcement
de l'attractivité des carrières des
praticiens hospitaliers qu'il faut
maintenir à l'hôpital parce que c'est la
colonne vertébrale de notre service
public hospitalier dans tous les
territoires et comme je l'avais dit les
ARS ont mis en application territoire
par territoire je le redis des solutions
alternatives pour qu'il n'y ait pas de
rupture de la chaîne des c'est le cas
aussi à Aubenas vous le savez les
services le service est obligé de fermer
la nuit mais c'est un service qui était
déjà aux grandes difficultés avant même
l'application de la loi rice ce n'est
pas nouveau les solutions qui ont été
mises en place permettent de garantir de
garantir la prise en charge des urgences
vitales par le maintien d'une ligne de
SMUR par même l'ajout d'une ligne
supplémentaire au niveau du territoire
pour les transferts secondaires
également le soutien aux
sapeurs-pompiers par la mise en place
d'une équipe paramédicale de médecine
d'urgence le renforcement de la maison
médicale de garde et puis la possibilité
pour l'hôpital de recruter sur des
statuts de praticiens de type 2 et avec
une prime supplémentaire jusqu'à + 30 %.
donc ce sont des mesures concrètes des
mesures concrètes qui permettent
d'améliorer les choses puisque d'ores et
déjà les anesthésistes qui manquaient à
l'hôpital d'Aubenas sont revenus nous en
avons un nombre suffisant et je ne doute
pas que ce soit aussi le cas pour les
urgences le plus rapidement possible je
vous remercie
je vous remets le ministre monsieur Brun
merci monsieur le ministre pour votre
éponge je le remets pas en cause votre
volonté d'avancée mais apparemment il y
a un petit décalage entre vos
informations et la réalité sur le
terrain et je vous renouvelle mon
invitation à venir Aubenas constater les
dégâts de votre politique merci je vous
remercie
la parole est à Monsieur Alexis jolie
pour le rassemblement national
merci madame la Présidente ma question
s'adresse à monsieur le ministre de
l'économie des finances et de la
souveraineté industrielle et numérique
qui n'est pas là qu'il est en train
d'écrire la suite de son roman monsieur
le ministre le bilan du gouvernement en
matière de pilotage notre stratégie
industrielle globale est absolument
désastreux l'histoire récente de
l'entreprise Photowatt dans ma
circonscription en est un exemple
particulièrement criant cette entreprise
française de production de panneaux
photovoltaïques connaît de graves
difficultés alors qu'elle constitue
pourtant notre principal atout
concurrentiel en matière de production
électrique solaire notamment face aux
produits chinois qui sont d'une qualité
et d'une longévité bien moindre cette
entreprise devrait pourtant se porter à
merveille puisque l'État aurait pu s'y
fournir en panneau solaire pour
alimenter la nouvelle centrale solaire
de crémalleville qui se trouve à 30 km à
vol d'oiseau deux photos watts justement
cette ancienne centrale nucléaire
fleuron industriel français unique au
monde fermé par le gouvernement Jospin
pour plaire au lobby écologiste monsieur
Paco écouter bien a pourtant été équipé
de 22000 panneaux solaires chinois et ce
alors que des f et le principal
actionnaire de Photowatt
aujourd'hui l'entreprise fait de nouveau
l'actualité puisqu'elle ne trouve
toujours pas de repreneur ainsi donc une
fois encore l'État lui-même mais en
concurrence notre propre industrie avec
celle de puissance étrangère qui
défendent elle leurs intérêts
économiques et ces situations se
multiplient partout sur le territoire
nous sommes en fin d'une véritable
prédation organisée contre le tissu
industriel français et contre notre
souveraineté pendant que l'État se
refuse à jouer son rôle de régulateur de
bouclier de protecteurs de nos intérêts
nationaux monsieur le ministre je
souhaite donc savoir quand cessera ce
désastreet d'économique industriel et
écologique et quand votre gouvernement
se décidera enfin à protéger les
entreprises stratégiques et les emplois
industriels français
la parole est à Madame Olivia Grégoire
ministre délégué chargé des PME du
Commerce de l'Artisanat et du Tourisme
déjà puisque votre question est quand
même très directement une question
relative à notre industrie ça n'est pas
Bruno Le Maire que j'ai à excusé mes
Roland Lescure qui est en ce moment même
en débat à la Chambre haute quant à vos
commentaires sur Bruno Le Maire il vous
appartiennent pour ce qui est de
photowatts à 2000% même pour ce qui est
pour ceux qui aident de photowatts pour
ceux qui seraient intéressés dans votre
groupe éventuellement par une réponse
sur cette question
c'est effectivement une entreprise
importante vous le savez comme moi une
entreprise des dernières impliquées dans
la fabrication des panneaux solaires
elle a connu une période face au début
des années 2000 elle était à l'époque le
troisième fabricant mondial comptant
plus de 1000 salariés 1200 exactement
avant le dumping asiatique ayant conduit
comme vous le savez elle est seulement
profonde des acteurs européens
l'entreprise elle a été reprise par EDF
en 2012 et je lis mes fiches si j'ai
envie d'ailleurs madame la députée merci
ce qui a permis d'en d'éviter la
fermeture elle rencontre un vrai
problème de compétitivité sur ce marché
qui est extrêmement tendu pourquoi parce
qu'elle ne dispose pas de la taille
critique aujourd'hui pour rentabiliser
les grands investissements qui sont très
lourds et qui sont absolument
nécessaires ces investissements doivent
être très réguliers aussi pour se mettre
au standard du marché cette situation
est la conduit comme vous le savez je
pense monsieur le député julie a une
réduction progressive de l'attaque de
l'activité de photowatts et ce depuis un
long moment puisque Photowatt ne compte
plus que 180 salariés au moment où je
vous parle la volonté du gouvernement
elle est claire la filiale du photo la
filière du photovoltaïque elle est
absolument stratégique c'est d'ailleurs
bien pour ça que vous trouverez au sein
du plan France 2030 l'objectif de 1
milliard d'euros directement dédié aux
financement du photovoltaïque et de
l'industrialisation des ENR dans notre
pays nous avons d'ailleurs plusieurs
vous le savez projet gigafactory à
l'étude dans ce sens et un projet loi
réindustrialisation qui arrive ce sera
enfin l'occasion de vous entendre sur ce
sujet merci merci beaucoup madame la
ministre
la parole est à Madame Christine le
nabot pour le groupe Renaissance
merci madame la Présidente ma question
s'adresse à la ministre déléguée chargée
des personnes handicapées en octobre
dernier le comité interministériel du
handicap chargé de définir coordonnées
évaluer les politiques conduites par
l'État en direction des personnes
handicapées a été l'occasion de tracer
une feuille de route pour l'ensemble des
membres du gouvernement du gouvernement
l'occasion aussi de faire le bilan sur
les actions menées depuis 2017 et
préparez la sixième Conférence nationale
du handicap plus de 500 personnes ont
participé à des groupes de travail
animés par différents ministères des
personnes en situation de handicap des
élus locaux des entreprises des
partenaires sociaux des opérateurs de
transport des professionnels
médico-sociaux des parlementaires et des
administrations une véritable
co-construction ces travaux
préparatoires ont mobilisé l'ensemble
des expertises d'usage du secteur pour
construire des solutions dans chaque
aspect de la vie quotidienne l'école les
déplacements l'accès à l'emploi la santé
le logement le sport la culture les
loisirs le 26 avril dernier a donc eu
lieu la conférence nationale handicap le
président de la République le ministre
des Solidarités et vous madame la
ministre avait rappelé qu'entre autres
aujourd'hui davantage d'enfants sont
scolarisés dans les écoles publiques le
taux de chômage des personnes en
situation de handicap est en baisse de 6
points le nombre d'apprentis a augmenté
l'accessibilité a été améliorée malgré
tout le chemin est encore long pour
faciliter les parcours atteindre
l'accessibilité universelle et favoriser
l'autonomie nous devons poursuivre la
simplification des démarches
administratives encore trop complexes
améliorer les délais traitement des
dossiers et trouver des solutions
adaptées aux besoins réels je terminerai
par les mots du président de la
République et je le cite que notre
politique en matière de handicap soit un
jalon sur le chemin de l'effectivité des
droits fondamentaux et universel de
l'école à l'emploi de la maison à la
Cité madame la ministre pourriez-vous
nous rappeler les principaux engagements
et les mesures phares qui vont permettre
d'améliorer le quotidien des 12 millions
de Français concernés par le handicap et
leur 8 millions d'aidants je vous
remercie je vous remercie la parole est
à Madame Geneviève dariussec ministre
délégué chargé des personnes handicapées
merci madame la présidente madame la
députée
Christine le nabourg je vous remercie de
votre question qui met en lumière la
Conférence nationale du handicap qui
s'est tenue mercredi dernier sous
l'autorité du Président de la République
qui est un rendez-vous important qui
permet de tracer la route pour les
années à venir en matière de handicap
qui permet d'avoir des objectifs forts
et les nôtres sont très forts bien sûr
le plein accès au droit des personnes en
situation de handicap et leur total
inclusion dans notre société et cette
CNH permet aussi de mettre en place les
moyens de d'arriver à ces objectifs
d'atteindre ses objectifs vous avez
décrit la co-construction 500 personnes
qui ont travaillé et donc 70 mesures
nouvelles que nous avons mis en oeuvre
et que nous allons mettre en oeuvre dans
les années à venir l'accessibilité
premier sujet nous sommes très en retard
dans notre pays ça a été reconnu par la
première ministre le président de la
République tous les ministres et je
crois vous tous ici un milliard cinq qui
est qui sont mis sur la table pour
pouvoir améliorer l'accessibilité dans
notre pays et donner un vrai coup de
fouet à la mise à l'accessibilité de
tous les espaces et les ERP les petits
VRP privées que nous allons aider ce
sont les ERP du quotidien pour les
personnes handicapées deuxième chose
bien sûr un service public du repérage
précoce et de la prise en charge précoce
repérez le plus tôt possible les
handicaps afin de ne pas créer de
surhandicap le meilleur intégration dans
l'école avec des moyens médico-sociaux à
l'intérieur des établissements scolaires
une meilleure intégration à l'université
une meilleure intégration dans la
formation professionnelle dans l'emploi
et je dois dire l'ouverture des droits
des travailleurs handicapés en ESAT qui
auront les mêmes droits que tous les
salariés et ce n'est aujourd'hui que
justice et puis bien sûr la création de
5 nouvelle solution création
indispensable car des personnes sans
solution sont beaucoup trop nombreuses
dans notre pays je vous remercie merci
beaucoup madame la ministre la parole
est à Monsieur Jean-Philippe Aqua Viva
pour le groupe iote merci madame la
Présidente ma question s'adresse madame
la Première ministre madame la Première
ministre la Corse ploie sous le
phénomène de la spéculation foncière et
immobilière avec une croissance
exponentielle du prix du terrain à bâtir
deux fois plus rapide que la moyenne des
régions françaises avec des zones au
loto de résidence secondaire atteint
jusqu'à 80% du parc de logement avec une
différence de pouvoir d'achat en
défaveur des résidences insulaires avec
des niches fiscales avantageant la
spéculation l'écorce vivent légitimement
cela comme une déposition ce n'est plus
tolérable des tensions sera vivent des
manifestations ont lieu des attentats
reprennent nous associons à cette
question les territoires qui vivent
quotidiennement sous le même tendance le
Pays Basque la Bretagne les territoires
alpins la Côte d'Azur les Vosges
littoral atlantique entre autres
la mission interministérielle sur la
trission des résidences principales et
d'autres travaux parlementaires
préconisent certaines mesures
intéressantes mais pour nous
insuffisantes si nous ne donnons pas
compétences aux collectivité de manière
différenciée par territoire d'agir de
manière suffisamment énergique sur ce
sujet la montagne accouchera d'une
souris et les déceptions seront trop
grandes des propositions vous ont été
faites en ce sens certaines ont
notamment été adoptés par des assemblées
territoriales délibérantes et par cet
Assemblée nationale elle-même à
plusieurs reprises trois types de
mesures nous semblent indispensables
tout d'abord l'exercice d'un droit de
préemption renforcé dans certaines zones
pour y restaurer un équilibre disparu
aujourd'hui ensuite la taxation des
transactions immobilières sur les
résidences secondaires à partir d'un
certain seuil enfin la garantie d'un
statut de résident dans le but d'avoir
un accès réservé au logement principal
et aux fonciers dans les documents
d'urbanisme j'ajouterai à celle-ci la
nécessité d'adapter le zéro
artificialisation nette à la réalité des
territoires êtes-vous prête madame la
Première ministre au regard de l'urgence
absolue de la situation
a créé un accord politique
transpartisant autour de ce type de
mesure proportionnées et différenciées
lors d'un prochain véhicule législatif
je vous remercie je vous remercie mon
cher collègue la parole est à Monsieur
Olivier Klein ministre délégué chargé de
la ville et du logement
merci madame la Présidente Mesdames et
Messieurs les Députés monsieur le
député Jean-Philippe Aquaviva vous nous
interpellez à juste titre sur l'enjeu du
logement encore celle de la spéculation
immobilière et foncière et des
difficultés de plus en plus grandes que
rencontrent les ménages corses pour se
loger et ceux qui habitent à l'année et
vous avez raison ces difficultés sont
bien réelles et comme vous l'avez
rappelé elle ne sont aussi partagées par
les territoires basques ou bretons
notamment face à ce constat nous
agissons avec la majorité vous le savez
le nombre de communes pouvant majorer la
taxe d'habitation sur les résidences
secondaires va être étendue dans
quelques semaines et les maires pourront
décider d'appliquer ou pas cette
majoration cette extension du zonage va
également permettre davantage de
communes d'appliquer les réglementations
existantes sur les meublés touristiques
à travers le numérotation
d'enregistrement et le changement
d'usage et vous l'avez rappelé vous
faites aussi partie du groupe de travail
que nous avons lancé avec Olivia
Grégoire et Dominique Faure afin
d'étudier ce problème majeur de la
pression du logement dans les zones
touristiques il y a aujourd'hui 73
propositions
et contributions qui sont sur l'établi
et sur le travail elles seront toutes
étudiées et nous vous donnerons avec
vous des réponses avant l'été par
ailleurs vous le savez bien évidemment
il y a aussi le comité stratégique entre
le gouvernement et la Corse qui
travaillent à cette question spécifique
et à tous les autres problématiques et
en jeu Corse et puis il y a le chantier
que nous a donné et madame la Première
ministre et le président de la
République des questions de
décentralisation du logement sur lequel
bien évidemment nous sommes à l'oeuvre
enfin je souligne la proposition de loi
déposée par la députée à Nagui le meurt
et le groupe Renaissance qui vise qui
est votre sujet à lutter contre
l'éviction des résidents permanents en
zone
retendue et cette proposition répond à
un grand nombre de vos attentes je vous
remercie
monsieur Aquaviva j'entends tous ces
propositions nous en avons faites ce que
je souhaite c'est vu l'urgence qu'un
accord politique global et qu'on répond
pas à côté mais mais questionnements
étaient vraiment très précis je vous
remercie je vous remercie mon cher
collègue la parole est à Monsieur Thomas
porte pour la France insoumise madame la
Présidente Monsieur le Ministre des
Transports chaque année en France 48 000
personnes D7 prématurément à raison de
la pollution à lui seul le secteur des
transports génère 30% des émissions pour
lutter contre ce drame humain et
écologique notre pays dispose d'un outil
formidable le Fred ferroviaire publique
un outil aujourd'hui menacé de
disparition par des logiques libérales
qui priorisent les objectifs de
rentabilité au détriment de l'urgence
environnementale nous avons appris que
le 18 janvier 2023 la Commission
européenne a lancé une commission
d'enquête approfondie sur Fret SNCF pour
déterminer si l'entreprise du site a
bénéficié d'aide publique à la rencontre
de la fameuse concurrence libre et non
fossés une enquête encouragée par la
procédure de filialisation de la SNCF
issue de la réforme du ferroviaire de
2018 que les cheminots ont massivement
combattu au moment où la loi européenne
sur le climat fait une obligation légale
de réduire les émissions de lieu d'au
moins 50% d'ici à 2030 Bruxelles a
décidé de lancer une nouvelle offensive
libérale en fin de liquider
définitivement l'opérateur historique et
public du Fred ferroviaire en France
Monsieur le Ministre sans outil public
et sans monopole d'État il n'y aura pas
de transition écologique possible
après 15 ans de libéralisation le bilan
est sans appel depuis 2006 date de
l'ouverture à la concurrence la part
modale est passée de 22% à 10% avec
comme corollaire le transfert de plus de
2 millions de camions sur nos routes
Fred SNCF a perdu 10 000 emplois passant
de 15000 cheminots en moins de 5000 le
fret a été saigné par les gouvernements
successifs qui ont favorisé la route au
détriment du rail allant un rebours des
annonces en grande pompe sur nos
objectifs climatiques la SNCF a fait le
choix de ne pas contester l'ouverture de
l'enquête pire elle prépare le terrain
pour faciliter la liquidation de fraises
SNCF monsieur le ministre vous avez
rencontré la commissaire européenne de
la concurrence allez-vous avoir le
courage de vous opposer à la possibilité
du discontinuité de l'activité qui
signerait la mort de Fred SNCF et serait
un nouveau scandale écologique pour
votre politique
je vous remercie
[Applaudissements]
la part ministre délégué chargé des
transports
[Applaudissements]
merci madame la Présidente Mesdames et
Messieurs les Députés monsieur le député
thomasport le sujet du frais de
ferroviaire est non seulement une
priorité mais il est suffisamment
important pour qu'on le dise pas tous
les jours des mensonges à son égard
dénigrant ainsi notre service public
ferroviaire et les cheminots et les
cheminots qui font marcher le
ferroviaire en France vous avez par un
tweet il y a encore quelques semaines
dit un mensonge de plus que le frère de
ferroviaire était abîmé par une décision
de fret SNCF et du gouvernement qui
visait à suspendre le train des primeurs
c'est faux chaque mot de votre tweet est
faux vous faites la même chose
aujourd'hui alors que le train reprend
son activité en ce moment même après
avoir été perturbé par les mouvements
sociaux vous faites la même chose avec
la procédure qui a été en effet engagé
le 18 janvier dernier par la Commission
européenne l'ouverture de la procédure
n'a pas à être contestée ou approuvé ni
par le gouvernement français ni par fret
SNCF ou le groupe SNCF elle a argument
après argument un combat à être mené que
nous menons et j'ai eu plusieurs
réunions d'ores et déjà avec la
vice-présente de la commission europ
pour en effet je crois que nous
partageons cet objectif préserver le
frais de ferroviaire en France préserver
un opérateur public de Fred ferroviaire
défendent Frat SNCF qui n'a rien à voir
dans ces difficultés avec la
filialisation que vous évoquez et la
réforme de 2018 puisque la procédure
ouverte par la commission porte sur
d'autres sujets et une autre période
revenez là encore au fait je pense que
ce sera plus simple pour le débat nous
avons mis en place en 2021 un plan
inédit le soutien aux frais de fer d'un
milliard d'euros qui est en train de se
déployer je n'en ai pas le mérite il a
été voté par cette majorité lors de la
législature précédente vous ne l'avez
pas soutenu ce plan il se déploie si
bien que les chiffres que vous donnez
qui sont dramatiquement vrai sont
désormais invalidés puisque il y a une
augmentation pour la première fois
depuis plus d'une décennie de la part du
Fred ferroviaire en France nous
continuerons nous investirons notamment
les contrats de plan état région dans
les infrastructures de frais de
ferroviaires j'espère que vous voterez
les crédits qui seront destinés au frais
de ferroviaire et au déploiement de ce
plan dans le prochain budget puisque
vous l'avez jamais fait c'est mieux que
de répondre des mensonges menons ce
combat
utilement ensemble je vous remercie
monsieur le ministre monsieur porte
il y a une réalité c'est que 40000
personnes décèdent des causes de la
pollution et votre politique elle est
responsable aujourd'hui de ces gens qui
décèdent de votre inaction politique
je vous remercie la parole est à
Monsieur Jean Tarlier pour le groupe
Renaissance
merci merci Madame à la présidente
monsieur le ministre des Transports
alors que le département du Tarn porte
encore les stigmates de Stevens le
risque d'une nouvelle ZAD en opposition
à la construction de l'autoroute à 69
entre Castres et Toulouse inquiète et
interpelle si la manifestation à ça ici
il y a 10 jours c'est de rouler sans
incident majeur et je tiens ici à
remercier les forces de leur présente en
nombre et les services de l'État qui ont
permis d'éviter tout débordement il est
intolérable que ce projet autoroutier
puisse être remis en cause par une
minorité de prétendues écologistes
radicalisés vous le savez le sud du Tarn
est un territoire enclavé qui souffre
comme beaucoup de territoires ruraux
d'un déficit d'attractivité depuis 30
ans l'ensemble des élus locaux le
département du Tarn la région aux côtés
les forces vives de ce département se
battent pour obtenir l'arrivée de la 69
les tarnés n'ignore pas que c'est ce
gouvernement en 2018 qui signale les
déclarations du type public par
l'intermédiaire de Madame Élisabeth
borne alors ministre des Transports que
c'est cette majorité qui sanctuarisa le
financement de dans le cadre de la loi
d'orientation des mobilités que c'est
enfin Jean castexte Premier ministre qui
annonça le choix du concessionnaire à
l'agorrigue à côté de Castres en raison
notamment des surcompensations
environnementales proposées alors que la
commission d'enquête environnementale a
rendu un avis positif que les travaux
préparatoires ont débuté le renoncement
de l'État serait une tragédie pour ce
bassin d'emploi de plus de 100000
personnes pour les habitants du sud du
Tarn favorables à plus de 75% à ce
projet d'autoroute selon un récent
sondage s'il est parfaitement légitime
que les nouveaux projets autoroutiers
fabs l'objet d'une revue à l'aune de
leur impact environnementale cette
question nous semble déjà avoir été
purgés dans le cadre de l'autoroute a69
et l'état de droit commande désormais
que le contrat de concession autoroutier
ainsi que les autorisations
administratives du Mans validé ne soit
pas remise en cause aussi Monsieur le
Ministre pouvez-vous ici venir lever les
inquiétudes des suites tarnées
concernant la 69 et préciser les
conditions dans lesquelles cette revue
des projets doit se dérouler je vous
remercie
c'est mon cher collègue la parole est à
monsieur Clément bonne ministre délégué
chargé des transports
[Applaudissements]
madame la Présidente Mesdames et
Messieurs les Députés monsieur le député
Jean tardlier merci de votre engagement
et des précisions que vous avez rappelé
sur ce projet je vous remercie aussi
d'avoir permis par votre action et celle
de quelques autres une expression claire
ou une nouvelle expression attendue des
élus locaux qui ont dans leur immense
majorité et tout le sensibilité
politique confondues j'ai l'occasion de
me m'entretenir avec beaucoup d'entre
eux dis les attentes dit leur soutien à
ce projet qui en effet discuter depuis
longtemps et qui a fait l'objet
d'engagement important à ces derniers
mois ces dernières années encore
récemment vous en avez rempli le contenu
et le calendrier la revue que j'évoque
elle ne doit pas susciter le fantasme ou
de doute il y a sous l'autorité de la
première ministre une revue des projets
autoroutiers qui portera sur un certain
nombre de réalisations qui ne sont pas
engagés et qui peuvent poser des
questions sur leur impact
environnemental sur leur coût sur le
coût des péages associés et il y aura
des décisions je les dis qui sous
l'autorité de la première mise seront
prises d'ici l'été et qui clarifieront
ce point s'agissant des projets qui sont
déjà engagés c'est évidemment une
situation
et cela ne veut pas dire que ne pas
chercher des discussions les
améliorations vous avez porté notamment
celles qui sont aujourd'hui en cours sur
le plan environnemental et je vous en
remercie nous pouvons regarder je les
recevrai encore dans les prochains jours
avec la société concessionnaire s'il y a
quelques améliorations supplémentaires
qui sont nécessaires c'est dans cet
esprit d'État de droit de respect des
engagements d'engagements
environnemental renforcé dans la période
que nous vivons c'est le sens de la
planification écologique que nous menons
que nous discuterons et que nous
avancerons comme vous l'avez indiqué je
vous remercie je vous remercie monsieur
le ministre
[Applaudissements]
international
la question s'adresse à Monsieur le
Ministre de la Santé depuis le lundi 6
février et la création du collectif les
infirmiers libéraux en colère le
gouvernement reçoit chaque jour des
courriers d'infirmiers libéraux qui n'en
peuvent plus afin de vous alerter sur
leurs conditions de travail ces croyez
sont restés jusqu'ici l'être morte les
infirmiers et disons et disons-le les
infirmières libérales car ce sont
majoritairement des femmes sont pourtant
un des maillons essentiels de notre
société pour assurer la continuité des
soins permettre à de nombreuses
personnes âgées de rester à leur
domicile et parfois même de les assister
jusqu'à la fin de vie leur importance
est connue de tous leur revendications
sont parfaitement légitimes mais encore
une fois elles ne sont pas écoutées car
oui obtenir une revalorisation des
honoraires et des indemnités devient
urgent après dix années passées sans que
le tarif des actes médicaux n'a été
réévaluée vous avez d'ailleurs évaluer
de nouveau le prix de la consultation
des médecins de 1,50 €, il y a quelques
jours quid des infirmières ajoutées à ça
les indemnités de déplacement qui sont
de 2,50 € par tragique quel que soit la
distance quand on connaît l'augmentation
du prix du carburant c'est un pur
scandale
ayant moi-même travaillé leur côté je
connais la pénibilité de cet emploi et
surtout le manque de considération de la
part de l'État pour celle-ci nous
n'avons cessé de chanter leur louange
pendant la crise du covid elles sont
elles ont désormais besoin de nous ce
n'est pas le moment de les oublier alors
Monsieur le Ministre allez vous attendre
que tous nos professionnels de santé
soient dans la rue fassent grève et
paralyse le pays nos infirmières
libérales attendent des réponses et des
actions merci je vous remercie ma chère
collègues la parole est à Monsieur
François Brown ministre de la santé et
de la prévention merci madame la
Présidente Mesdames et Messieurs les
Députés madame la députée Christine
Loire
je peux pas vous laisser dire que le
gouvernement méprise ou ne prend pas en
considération les demandes des
infirmiers au contraire c'est une
réforme globale qui est conduite sur
l'autorité de la première ministre
concernant cette profession d'infirmiers
trois points le premier concernant le
rémunération la mise en place du bilan
de Soins Infirmier ce fameux BSI a été
un succès à tel point que nous doublons
les engagements financiers sur la mise
en place de ce BSI sur la période 2020
2024 jusqu'à 217 millions d'euros pour
justement favoriser des prises en charge
qui s'éloignent simplement du paiement à
l'acte mais qui prennent en charge la
personne dans sa globalité en
particulier les patients chroniques de
la même façon je vous rappelle que les
frais kilométriques peuvent maintenant
être moduler territoire par territoire
en fonction des difficultés des
territoires c'était déjà le cas pour la
montagne maintenant ça peut être le cas
dans chaque département et dans chaque
territoire nous agissons aussi sur leur
formation à la rentrée prochaine la
formation de trois ans des infirmières
infirmières va être totalement rénovée
pour mieux répondre aux besoins de santé
et dans le même temps nous modifions
leur décret de compétence pour justement
ne plus être simplement une liste
d'actes mais bien agir sur les missions
que nous confions aux affirmiers enfin
dans leur exercice professionnel nous
développons l'exercice
pluriprofessionnel l'exercice en groupe
et nous avons ici même pu discuter et
pouvoir mettre en place l'accès sous
contrôle enfin sous supervision plutôt
du médecin traitant l'accès aux
infirmiers directement pour des prises
en charge de soins spécifiques comme par
exemple le suivi des plaies chroniques
c'est donc bien une modification
profonde et globale du métier
d'infirmier qui est en route et elle est
en route parce que justement nous
écoutons nous avons écouté et nous
continuons à discuter avec les
organisations représentatives des
infirmiers hospitaliers comme libéraux
je vous remercie merci merci Monsieur le
Ministre madame loi oui merci monsieur
le ministre monsieur le ministre j'ai
reçu les infirmières libérales pendant
les vacances parlementaires c'est pas du
tout ce qu'elles m'ont dit donc je vous
ramènerai leur revendications je vous
remercie
la parole est à Madame Anne Le Hénin
pour le groupe horizon merci madame la
Présidente Monsieur le Ministre du
Logement dans son 28e rapport annuel sur
l'état du mal logement en France en 2023
la Fondation avait pierre montre que
lors de la séparation conjugale la
précarisation des conditions de logement
est bien plus fréquente pour les femmes
parmi les 420 coupes 420 000 couples qui
se séparent chaque année il est
malheureusement fréquent que la femme
soit contrainte de quitter le logement
conjugal au familial seul ou avec leurs
enfants qui sont parfois très jeunes
mais pour les femmes en instance de
divorce ou de séparation cherchant à se
loger dans le parc social c'est un
véritable parcours du combattant qui
s'annonce elles doivent tout d'abord
fournir une preuve de la volonté de se
séparer ou de divorcer et que qu'elle
cette décision soit effective et que le
processus de séparation est engagée la
réglementation encadrant les
attributions dans le parc social indique
qu'en cas de divorce c'est l'ordonnance
de non conciliation établies par le juge
aux affaires familiales qui fait foi ce
document est parfois difficile à obtenir
et la demande de logement ne peut
intervenir avant que la procédure de
divorce était butée et que la demandeuse
se soit mise en lien avec un avocat les
associations ainsi que certains
bailleurs sociaux reconnaissent que la
réglementation actuelle ne prend pas
suffisamment en compte la phase
transitoire des justificatifs sont
également nécessaires pour se
désolidariser du revenu fiscal commun
lorsque les ressources du couple dépla
dépassent le plafond requis pour accéder
à un logement social quand bien même
l'ex conjointe n'aurait pas de
ressources propres enfin la clause de
solidarité du bail lorsque des dettes
ont été contractées durant la vie
commune est un obstacle conséquent car
quelle que soit l'origine de ces impayés
la personne demandeuse doit s'en
acquitter si elle souhaite obtenir un
nouveau logement social aussi Monsieur
le Ministre quelle mesure de
gouvernement entend mettre en oeuvre
pour aider et accompagner ces milliers
de femmes à se loger rapidement et
dignement je vous remercie je vous
remercie la parole est à Monsieur
Olivier Klein ministre délégué chargé de
la ville et du logement
merci madame la Présidente Mesdames et
Messieurs les Députés madame la députés
Anne Le Hénaff votre question pose une
question extrêmement grave celle de la
décohabitation au moment de séparation
et de divorce et ces moments
particulièrement difficiles sont souvent
des moments de grande tension vous
sommes évidemment extrêmement mobilisés
avec ma collègue Isabelle Rome et
l'ensemble du gouvernement pour lutter
contre toutes les formes de
discrimination discrimination dans
l'accès au logement et en particulier
celle de des femmes et des femmes dans
des situations de séparation en décembre
dernier nous avons d'ailleurs signé une
charte de non discrimination dans
l'accès au logement privé avec la fnaïm
et nous travaillons actuellement avec
les autres organismes pour signer ce
type de charte de non discrimination
avec des formations des agents
immobiliers en particulier vous l'avez
rappelé lors un changement de logement
pour cause de procédure de divorce il
faut évidemment aujourd'hui un document
de non conciliation et il est difficile
de changer cette réglementation pour
éviter toute forme d'abus et au moins
nous travaillons avec les différents
ministères concernés à simplifier les
démarches administratives de nos
concitoyens et de nos concitoyens pour
les situations les plus graves celle de
violence nous avons évidemment des
dispositions d'hébergement d'urgence sur
laquelle nous sommes très attentifs plus
de 10000 places ont été ouvertes et la
première ministre a annoncé il y a peu
encore 1000 places supplémentaires pour
cette année
2023 c'est un gain évidemment important
mais il n'est pas suffisant pour régler
toutes les problèmes de décohabitation
de mutation en particulier pour les cas
que vous indiquez il faut continuer à
travailler à produire du logement
puisque une des difficultés aussi celles
de du manque de logement et qui accentue
cette difficulté dont vous parlez mais
je peux vous assurer de notre
mobilisation complète je vous remercie
je vous remercie monsieur le ministre la
séance des questions gouvernement est
terminée la séance est suspendue